parce qu'on est en campagne des
législatives dans deux semaines un césar
oui c'est même louis dans dix jours la
cc dimanche dimanche 12 pour le premier
tour et dimanche par l'impression d'être
en campagne non déjà la campagne
présidentielle pas forcément
l'impression d'être en campagne et celle
des législatives on a eu l'impression au
début quand il y avait jean luc
mélenchon qui faisait l'alliance à
gauche et puis sinon de nouveaux portant
la campagne et l'ong al dur 50 jours
mais on n'a pas vraiment la sensation
d'être d'être dans le fût de la campagne
période de réserve donc mais des
ministres qui sont au coeur de
l'actualité vous l'avez compris bon vous
réagissez sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr
sur twitch je prends vocation je les lis
adina et on essaie d'y répondre ensemble
ça arrive souvent dina des ministres
auditionnés comme ça alors souvent je
sais pas mais assez régulièrement oui ça
fait partie des fonctions du sénat il
doit à la fois voter les lois mais il a
aussi une fonction de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement donc c'est vrai
que c'est normal que le sénat auditionne
des ministres ils ont notamment
auditionner olivier ferrand pendant le
we day on l'a vu pendant la promo 1000 2
10e il ne donne pas que des ministres il
avait auditionné oui oui bien sûr encore
ce sont des commissions des commissions
dans quatre commissions des lois des
deux commissions de la culture
différentes commissions du sénat qui
dans leurs travaux ont ces auditions
pour pour être éclairé sur sur le
déroulé des événements et donc ils
lisent auditionne différentes
personnalités il se trouve que assez
régulièrement se sont égaux ni
personnalité qui me vient en tête
peut-être que le parallèle est douteux
mais lorsque je pense audition au sénat
je pense tout de suite avec centre ben
alaoui assez difficile de ne pas penser
à lui profitant mais je suis pas il se
mercier parce que c'est un peu ce qui a
mis le sénat sous le feu des projecteurs
se souvient il ya eu cette fameuse
affaire mais là qu'a été très étonné à
l'été 2010 8 et en 2019 il a été
il ya eu les auditions du sénat et en
fait ça a été un événement public sénat
exploser ses audiences on pressent qu'on
dit le savoir est tous dans la douleur
que le sénat pouvait exactement c'est
quelque chose parce que le sénat
travaille un peu dans l'ombre ou parle
beaucoup de l'assemblée nationale mais
un petit peu moins du sénat est en fait
à ce moment là tout le monde s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait ces fameuses
audition ça a été extrêmement suivi et
ç'a eu un intérêt puisque puisqu'à
l'époque les sénateurs ce sont mes
féliciter d'avoir mis en lumière des
dérives des dysfonctionnements dans la
chaîne à l'ordre plusieurs questions on
a le droit déjà de refuser d aller alors
non
vous et moi on est convoqué on peut dire
non non on travaille au figaro alors
vous avez ça dépend il ya les ministres
qui sont cons qui sont convoqués et la
servante dans le dans le devoir de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement corps
donc les nids sont tenus de s'y rendre
après quand ce sont des auditions de
citoyens c'est encore un quart un petit
peu différent on peut être invités à se
rendre à une audition mais mais il n'y a
pas cette même obligation en revanche
des ministres en effet c'est dans les
dents les devoirs dans l'est dans les
compétences du sénat donc oui si on est
auditionné par le par le sénat on doit
s'y rendre normalement cette audition
devrait commencer à 17 heures donc au
sénat on y attend gérald darmanin et
donc amélie oudéa castéra est-ce que
c'est pas un petit coup de pression de
la part du sénat parce que le sénat il
est pas la majorité de droite le sénat
est de majorité de droite alors les
sénateurs vous le diront pas que c'est
un coup de pression notamment chez eux
et ils vous diront qu'ils sont dans leur
dans leurs devoirs parce que en effet ça
fait partie de leurs compétences après
forcément surtout vu la période dans
laquelle on est basse et ça devient un
instrument politique puisque la droite
c'est l'opposition la droite s'est battu
contre emmanuel man contre emmanuel
macron pendant cette campagne la droite
joue aussi actuellement sur des thèmes
on parle des thèmes sécuritaires donc
qui sont les thèmes de la droite et la
droite reproche à emmanuel macron de ne
ne pas aidé est trop faible sur les
thèmes sécuritaires donc forcément ça
prend une dimension très très beau lui
alors autre question peut-être un peu
provoc mais bon très bien gérald
darmanin au sénat m interrogé on va
parler du fond dans un instant
alexandre banana à été interrogé lui
aussi plusieurs et après on en fait quoi
tout ce à quoi ça sert alors ça dépend
si ça peut permettre de faire ressortir
des vérités qui n'étaient pas établis
jusque là selon le déroulé de l'audition
si on apprend des nouvelles choses les
sénateurs peuvent ensuite
potentiellement transmettre à la justice
des choses qui seraient utiles ça peut
aussi aboutir à une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire est bidon ça c'est
possible oui ça c'est horrible sauf si
quelque chose est ouvert par la justice
parce qu'on ne peut pas être on ne peut
pas être jugé deux fois donc il peut pas
y avoir une commission denquête en même
temps que qu'une procédure de justice
mais en effet ça peut aboutir à ça et
puis surtout s'il s'avère que que les
ministres menthe devant les sénateurs en
pleine audition c'est quelque chose qui
est répréhensible c'est un serment à
faire au 2e mais c'est lui c'est ça en
fait on ne peut pas mentir ne peut pas
mentir en audition devant des sénateurs
alors darmanin et est allée devant la
commission des lois en mars dernier et
figurez-vous 1 c'était sur la question
de l'accueil des migrants pas autant
médiatique il risque d'être un petit peu
asticoter cette fois on va reparler de
gérald darmanin mais vous voyez regarder
sur ces images c'était lors de la
réunion lundi après ces fameuses
événement avec le préfet l'allemand eon
voix à amélie oudéa castéra la ministre
des sports est les nouvelles c'est un
baptême du feu pour halo cyr oui alors
c'est un début assez en questionnant
plus facile quand même c'est sûr surtout
qu'il ya encore quelques temps elle
était joueuse de tennis c'est pas du
tout quelqu'un te dirait de la
fédération france mais c'est pas
quelqu'un qui vient de la poly nantes ce
soir alors on n'a jamais fait voilà l a
jamais eu de mandat électif c'est la
première fois qu'elle fait la politique
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure ça fait
douze jours qu'elle est en place oui
donc c'est vrai qu'on a connu des débuts
plus facile on a vu des ministres des
sports qui traversait leur période grise
une star de sport dans l'anonymat le
plus total et pas toujours leurs
ministères dont on entend le plus
marrant après on savait que ce
quinquennat là on allez en entendre
parler parce que une mention a été
ajoutée à son collègue et willis des
sports et des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui sienne en 2001
kappeler forcément ça c'est la grande
question de l'organisation des jo qui
devrait se poser cet après-midi parce
que finalement si on n'avait pas les jo
en deux ans et la coupe du monde de
rugby l'année prochaine on se poserait
peut-être moins la question de campinas
la politique pour oui vous avez raison
mais tu m'intrigues capacité à organiser
ces événements dans les wii dans les
mois c'est sûr que là ça prend une
dimension qui est totalement différente
parce que parce qu'en fait ça questionne
sur la capacité de la france à organiser
des événements sportifs de très grande
ampleur on a la coupe du monde de rugby
l'année prochaine et puis les jo la
france s'est battue pour les accueillir
pour les accueillir en france il faut
qu'elle se montre à la hauteur de ça et
c'est vrai que quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir on se dit mais
donc les jo qui dure plusieurs semaines
comment ça va se passer ça va pas être
ça tous les soirs donc c'est moins là ça
ne peut qu'être être utilisés et que
nourrir 2 1 et des inquiétudes pour les
événements à venir je salue arthur sur
lefigaro.fr ipaq now si vous nous posez
vos questions j'en vois quelques unes
mais on va y venir je vous promets on va
on va y répondre tiens comment réagi
emmanuel macron à tout ça parce que bon
12 jours que ce gouvernement est en
place combien presque un mois et demi
maintenant qu'il est élu on le voit
assez peu mais ça c'est une affaire
importante hier soir il est interrogé il
était un sommet européen bruxelles mais
question à la fin d'une d'un petit micro
tendu comme on dit il n'a pas voulu
répondre non c'est vrai que c'est
toujours difficile dont on n'est pas
dans le secret de ce que pensent
emmanuel macron mais ce qu'on voit en
tout cas c'est qu'il est en retrait il
est très discret on peut se dire qu'il
est qui gardent peut-être une position
de surplomb aussi par rapport à tout ça
il vient d'être réélu
il va pas se mêler à toutes les
polémiques qui agitent son gouvernement
et puis on a vu qu'il y avait les
revenus sur le terrain il était dans un
centre hospitalier à cherbourg demain il
va marseille avec son vomi de
l'éducation nationale pour parler
d'école donc on voit qu'en fait lui les
balaurs vous me dites qui s'occupe pas
de ce qui relève du gouvernement mais
dans des polémiques ce qui s'agit des
dégâts justement là il est plutôt dans
les grands chantiers du quinquennat iard
il a parlé de l'hôpital on sait que la
situation l'hôpital extrêmement tendue
demain il va parler de l'école qu'il a
déjà misé comme un grand chantier de ce
quinquennat donc il se perd pas vraiment
dans les polémiques et d'ailleurs il se
disait ce matin en conseil des ministres
bah oui c'est intéressant oui c'est la
preuve parole du gouvernement olivier
grégoire qui disaient qu'ils maniaient
l'acro a mentionné ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir mais sans trop s'y attarder
donc finalement peut-être qu'il veut un
petit peu minimisé les choses et puis
montré que macky ya du boulot parce que
quand il ya des polémiques comme ça ça
donne croyez vraiment qu'on ne s'est pas
attardé sur cette question ce matin en
conseil des ministres vous ce sont les
propos d'olivier grégoire à la sortie
vous compliqué de le savoir forcément
mais en tout cas ce que ça dit c'est
qu'il ya une tentative de l'exécutif de
minimiser les faits et ne pas en faire
un événement médiatique d'amilly
médiatique que ces actions oui olivier
grégoire qui a dit aussi ce matin est ce
que tout a été bien fait non elle a
répondu à eux ce qui est sûr aussi
peut-être une volonté du gouvernement de
montrer qui se remet en question ah ça
m'intéresse parce que justement nos
confrères de bfm nous disent de source
sûre apparemment que alexis kohler le
secrétaire général de l'elysée aurait
dit à darmanin d'arrêter de dire qu'on
était responsable de rien ce qui va dans
le sens de mon père d'olivia guara midi
et même ceux cette interview qui a donné
germaneau 20h aussi qui a été jugée
étrange par matignon et l'elysée voilà
donc il aurait eu une forme de recadrage
du chef de l'état sur sur gérald
darmanin 16h42 nous sommes en direct
nous attendons à l'est un peu plus de
vingt minutes nous verrons si les
ministres permettent d'arriver en retard
au sénat ça c'est la grande question ce
serait mal commencé oui ce serait mal
commencé pour une audition d'environ
deux heures c'est ce qu'on nous dit on
voit les deux heures de questions des
sénateurs de commission commission des
lois et commissions de culture et voilà
alors justement revenons à gérald
darmanin est-ce qu'il a changé de ton ce
soir est ce que c'est possible parce que
on l'a vue offensif lacan et demande
depuis deux jours trois jours quatre
jours maintenant alors est ce qui va
changer de ton une fois de plus c'est
difficile à dire mais en tout cas est ce
qu'il va maintenir sa version des faits
depuis trois jours c'est ce qui fait dès
le début il a fait le choix d'évoquer
ses 30000 à 40000 supporters de
liverpool qui serait en tort qu'ils
auraient des faux billets oui alors ça
c'est sa première excuse oui c'est ça ce
sont les supporteurs de liverpool les
anglais exactement sans remettre en
cause le dispositif de sécurité qui
aurait été à la hauteur donc qu'est-ce
qui va changer cette version on sais pas
en tout cas ce que les sénateurs veulent
ils ont dit à plusieurs reprises bruno
retailleau là encore dit ce matin ils
veulent la vérité donc on peut
s'attendre exactement on peut s'attendre
à ce qu'il le fasse qu'il retrace le fil
des événements de manière très précise
et puis surtout les sénateurs ont dit
qu'ils voulaient avoir les sources d
information de dénis des ministres parce
qu'en fait ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi on a des versions il ya des
chiffres qui sont 6 1 sont donnés je
salue chardon bleu john clair sur sur
lefigaro.fr t1 chardons bleus qui me dit
il pour au moins présenter des excuses
au nom de la france aux anglais et aux
espagnols ça c'est peut-être qu'on
attend un peu d'eux oui qu'on passe
c'est ce qui commence à revenir de plus
en plus marine le pen l'a dit ce matin
elle a dit qu'il fallait qu'il présente
des excuses parce qu'en fait on l'accuse
de risquer un incident diplomatique avec
les britanniques parce que forcément
c'est pas toujours très agréable de se
faire entendre que que ses supporters
sachant qu'en plus si on a déjà eu des
finales de ligue des champions et
liverpool les supporters sont déjà allés
dans d'autres pays c'est vrai ça
rarement des générations mais c'est son
excuse il dit que j'étais chaque fois
qu'il ya des problèmes c'était avec de
supporter anglais voilà mais forcément
c'est pas très étonnant que du côté des
britanniques se soit pas très bien pris
donc donc marine le pen notamment avec
la rive le fait justement elle était à
la radio ce matin elle a demandé sa
démission et puis elle présentait des
candidats dans le pas de calais pour les
législatives évidemment premières
questions qu'on lui pose cette affaire
du stade de france écoutez sa réponse je
rappelle qu'il est ministre en charge de
la sécurité qu'il n'a pas le droit de
raconter n'importe quoi de truquer des
informations pour tromper l'opinion de
tronquer publiquement des faits de
nature pénale pour arranger ses affaires
électorales
le sens de l'état que l'on attend d'un
ministre de la république les exigences
de neutralité de probité dans la gestion
des affaires publiques interdisent ce
type de comportement au premier chef le
responsable de ce fiasco c'est gérald
darmanin surtout c'est gérald darmanin
on tombe sur sur gérald darmanin elle
est dans son rôle oui première opposante
enfin il se veut en tout cas être la
première opposante à emmanuel macron
c'était la finaliste de la campagne
présidentielle évidemment en plus elle
en campagne quand même pour sa
réélection dans le pas de calais donc
elle est totalement dans son rôle de
mettre l'accent sur cette
irresponsabilité du ministre et ce matin
elle a même demandé sa démission on y
croit vraiment une démission de george
foreman ans
en politique ne jamais dire jamais mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas bon je
comprends non mais ça fait cinq ans
qu'il est en poste il a été reconduit
c'est vraiment devenu un poids lourd du
gouvernement et puis c'est pas la
première fois qu'il est un peu sous le
feu des critiques emmanuel macron il a
toujours renouvelé sa confiance et c'est
pas non plus franchement dans l'habitude
emmanuel macron de se laisser influencer
par ses opposants donc j'ai du mal à
penser qu'il pourrait plier sous la
pression de la classe politique oui oui
mais on verra on verra on a vu que
c'était pas forcément dans les habitudes
des manuels macron de plier notamment on
a vu sur la sphère abad récemment il a
du mal à être compris de l'autre côté de
la manche parce que il ya une forme de
tradition anglo saxonne où dès qu'un
ministre est une erreur hop il
démissionne et là on comprend pas
forcément en angleterre tiens on va
parler du fond évidemment il nous reste
allez un petit quart d'heure avant avant
le début des auditions mais sur
l'attitude on l'a vu très offensif est
ce qu'il donne des gages sécuritaire on
a donné l'idée du côté de l'exécutif
d'un gouvernement qui donne des gages à
gauche ah oui la bête bornes la
nomination de pap ndiaye lô au ministère
de l'éducation nationale une grande
partie de la campagne de la fin de
campagne axée sur l'écologie avec ses
deux ministres de l'écologie lui joue à
fond la caution droite la gérald
darmanin ce qui ne prend pas justement
ce rôle
tu lui donnes emmanuel macron finalement
alors oui et non parce qu'en même temps
qu'on vous regardez bien ce qu'il dit
le parti pris c'est de dire que le
dispositif de sécurité a fonctionné
alors évidemment il remet pas en cause
l'action de la police alors que
des images ont pu parfois surprendre
parce qu'on peut voir des scènes de
fabrication moyenne de ce que me dit
ibra nateur pas facile à dire faut
surtout expliquer pourquoi ils ont
utilisé du gaz lacrymogène entre deux
simples fraudeurs donc évidemment ça
c'est la méthode c'est notamment ça fait
partie des méthodes qui sont encadrés
par le préfet didier lallement donc
gérald darmanin normes et passants en
cause en revanche le fait de mettre la
faute entre guillemets sur les
supporters britanniques c'est aussi ne
pas évoquer cette délinquance qu'on a vu
samedi soir parce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler qu'il ya des supporters qui se
sont fait voler leur billet qui sont
fait agresser parfois physiquement oui
on a même un article qui est sorti après
midi sur lefigaro.fr vous pouvez
d'ailleurs retrouver pas même de
violence et d'agression sexuelle avec
des mains baladeuses de certaines
personnes sur des jeunes femmes qui sont
faits à gré à gré c'est qu'ils sont fait
voler leur sac est alors justement le
fait que gérald darmanin mais plutôt
l'action sur les supporters ça fait dire
à ses opposants de droite que finalement
qu'est ce qu'il essaye de faire c'est
envoyer des petits clins d'oeil à
l'électorat mélenchonistes est donc
plutôt à la gauche parce que la
seine-saint-denis c'est un département
où jean luc mélenchon a fait des scores
énorme on sait qu'il est très fort dans
les quartiers populaires donc on et
demande leur stratégie politique alors
est ce qu on y est je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas c'est ce que les opposants
essaye de dire ils disent que justement
le le fait de prendre ce parti plutôt
que de s'opposer aux supporters et de ne
pas dénoncer de possibles voyous
délinquants qui viendrait de
seine-saint-denis c'est finalement allé
dans le plutôt dans le sens des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon on peut
rappeler les faits peut-être
sans cette interpellation sans vite
peut-être il semble on va vérifier ça un
seul onglet donc les supporters il est
visiblement pas est-ce que des
supporters britanniques auraient
vraiment volé agressé d'autres
supporters britanniques c'est vrai que
c'est aussi voilà ça c'est une question
et puis
lundi matin à la radio à melwood à
castéra la ministre des sports dits oui
il y avait des jeunes des quartiers les
alentours puis dans la conférence de
presse l'après-midi question est très
vite écartée avec une toute petite
concession ou lorsque gérald darmanin
dit oui on était très bien préparée
contre le hooliganisme
peut-être un peu moins contre la
délinquance mais cette question est très
vite écartée oui il ya clairement une
gêne sur le sujet en tout cas on veut
pas trop s'y attarder le souci c'est que
il ya des témoignages en fait les
journalistes étaient présents samedi
soir et puis évidemment avec les réseaux
sociaux déjà parce que ce ne sont pas
des supporters anglais voilà exactement
par dessus les barrières et puis voilà
il ya ce que tout le monde a vu il ya ce
que les journalistes ont relaté est en
effet les journalistes parlent
minoritairement de violence qui
viendrait des supporters britanniques et
puis on est dans un département où
il ya aussi de la délinquance donc c'est
quelque chose qui est à prendre en
compte est ce qu'il ya une forme
d'inconscience dans l'attitude de gérald
darmanin parce que l'ue les ministres de
l'intérieur intérieur des frontières
finalement mais ce qui se passe à
l'étranger il a fait fille complètement
de la dimension diplomatique on a
l'impression c'est c'est toute la
question c'est pour ça que qui as est
ce fameux enjeux de présenter des
excuses aux britanniques parce que c'est
vrai que c'est risqué c'est risqué de
faire ça après est ce qu'il y à un
calcul derrière quel est-il c'est encore
difficile à dire et c'est justement
aussi ce que l'audition va pas pouvoir
clarifier
aujourd'hui c'est encore très floues
mais en tout cas les les demande de
présenter des excuses ce fonds ce fonds
pesant tout et c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément le moment d'être en froid avec
avec nos amis britanniques pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent les 16h51 mafalda nous
pose une question on a déjà répondu mais
c'est vrai que de plus en plus de monde
et on va y répondre à nouveau quel est
l'objectif de cette audition au sénat
que peuvent faire les sénateurs
rappelez-nous dina à quoi sert cette
audition qu'on attend un dizaine de
minutes oui belle et les sénateurs l'ont
dit ils veulent obtenir la vérité donc
il faut s'attendre à ce qu'on ait un un
déroulé à ce qu une sorte de
reconstitution des faits en fait ils
vont probablement demander où était le
ministre de l'intérieur et la ministre
des sports à ce moment là il ya eu des
photos qui ont circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux on les voyait on les voyait
autour autour du stade ils vont sûrement
ils vont aussi leur demander leurs
sources les sénateurs ont vraiment
insisté là dessus ils veulent savoir
d'où viennent des informations dont
disposent les ministres parce que ça
peut être un peu tendu ce que qu'on a
voulu avoir des réponses cinglantes que
celle que gérald darmanin a donné aux
journalistes comme on le disait il ya un
contexte politique est quand même très
particulier on est en campagne
le sénat et de majorités de droite donc
l'opposition d' emmanuel macron
forcément il peut y avoir des tensions
après ça va être ça va dépendre aussi de
la manière dont les ministres jouent le
jeu et puis la ministre des sports
amélie oudéa castéra c'est la première
fois qu'un support est à cet exercice
donc est-ce qu'elle va aller à la
bataille je sais pas après c'est là
aussi qu'elle va nous montrer de quelle
envergure politique allez donc ça va
être pour elle aussi une épreuve assez
marquante est donc la question qui suit
après d'accord gérald darmanin et
auditionné en compagnie d'amélie oudéa
castéra pendant près de deux heures et
ensuite se passe quoi que peut faire le
sénat et ensuite le sénat peut
transmettre ces informations à la
justice
si plus tard il s'avère que les
ministres ont menti devant les sénateurs
ces quelques quelque chose qui est aussi
répréhensible par la justice et puis il
ya aussi la possibilité de créer une
d'ouvrir une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
qui peut se faire si la justice ne s'est
pas saisi des faits ou bien en
complément de la justice a peut pas être
exactement sur le même sujet mais le
sénat peut continuer d'utiliser ces
outils d'action de contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement pour essayer encore
d'éclaircir d'éclaircir cette histoire
donc voilà pour les enjeux des deux
prochaines heures au sénat
on va se pencher sur le fond parce qu'il
ya plusieurs questions les grandes
questions qui seront posées tout à
l'heure au sénat première question les
faux billets parce que ça c'est ce qu'a
mis en avant gérald darmanin les
chiffres qu'il donne il va devoir
s'expliquer dinars mais alors lui il
évoque depuis le début 30000 à 40000
faux billets et il explique que ce
serait justement pour l'industrie alors
voilà une fraude massive du striatum
qu'ils utilisent il explique que plus
30000 à 40000 supporters britanniques
auraient essayé de s'introduire dans le
stade aurait essayé de passer avec les
faux billets ce qui aurait donc pour
comme pour conséquence de créer cette
foulée ce débordement et cette situation
qui a dégénéré le problème c'est que
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec
ces chiffres déjà c'est là qu'on a des
versions différentes parce que des
hommes l'improbable oui sa pop bas parce
que déjà 48 supporters ça se voit oui je
vous comptez vous les journalistes qui
sont sur place ils expliquent qu'ils
n'ont pas vu 40000 supporters qui
étaient à l'extérieur et puis donc il ya
un petit peu une bataille des chiffres
alors il faut bien se tenir on a on a le
l'uefa qui dit avoir recensé 2860
billets qui auraient été falsifiés ça
peut être plus mais on a quand même un
écart énorme oui sans cela les chiffres
dans les manifestations entre la police
et des pétales attend exactement c'est
ça et puis on a aussi la ratp en c'était
écrit d'ailleurs dans un dans un article
qui est diffusée sur sur le site du
figaro la ratp expliqué au figaro avoir
transporté jusqu'au stade de france oui
il ya sept moyens et bien sûr un moyen
de souder durée de cette manière sur
hill's évoqué 69 mille personnes
sachant que ces quatre-vingt mille
places le stade de france alors tout le
monde au japon évidemment venez de loin
on parlerait de ne pas parier sans
l'accès au stade de france le rer est
l'axé principal secteur oil au stade de
france est très peu de parkings des
gares ya pas vraiment d'autre j'ai pas
très très bien desservi c'est un peu à
l'extérieur de paris non mais donc 69
fils personnes qui viendraient en aéro
aileron métro ça veut dire soixante
mille autres qui seraient venus en cars
par leurs propres moyens ça paraît quand
même
voilà exactement donc ça c'est la
première question les faux billets on
imagine que les sénateurs vont
l'augmenter roger schall darmanin qui
lui un accuse très clairement cette et
il reste il reste là dessus et je suis
depuis trois jours deuxième question
l'impréparation comment
s'explique depuis quelques jours du côté
du gouvernement alors que alors ça fait
trois mois que sa 8e finale doit avoir
lieu parce qu'elle ne devait pas avoir
lieu alors c'est mais c'est aussi ça le
sujet c'est que au départ ça devait
avoir lieu à saint-pétersbourg
évidemment avec la guerre en ukraine pas
étonnant cette finale à halle rue
emmanuel macron a poussé pour que cette
finale se tiennent à paris donc c'est
quelque chose qui s'en souvient bien sûr
pour le hockey voilà c'était un élément
de fierté on l'attendait cette finale
donc habituellement il faut plus que
trois mois pour l'organiser mais à
partir du moment où la france l'a voulue
ou emmanuel macron 1 personne a poussé
pour avoir cet événement dans la
capitale forcément on s'attendre à ce
que le dispositif de sécurité tiennent
derrière or là alors gérald darmanin a
reconnu
avoir été un peu peut-être dépassé par
le nombre de personnes qui étaient
présentes mais c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement surprenant surtout quand on
sait une fois de plus que dans un an il
ya la coupe du monde de rugby et dans
deux ans il ya les jo quoi et alors une
question justement sur ce problème c'est
en lien joseph harris qui nous dit
quelqu'un peut m'expliquer comment le
préfet l'allemand est toujours en poste
parce que c'est lui qui est censé
coordonner cette question de la sécurité
sur ces grands événements et c'est pas
la première fois qu'il est au coeur
d'une polémique c'est très politique
aussi tout ça c'est une question qui
revient beaucoup il est en poste depuis
2000 19 et c'est vrai que il ya des
critiques incessantes sur sa manière de
faire les choses on lui reproche une
manière un peu brutale de gérer la
sécurité une certaine froideur après
jusqu'à maintenant et il a toujours été
par reconduit parce que son poste
n'était pas mis en cause mais en tout
cas il a été conforté dans sa position
et on l'a vu ces derniers jours gérald
darmanin n'a pas remis en cause l'action
du préfet didier lallement donc ai dit
que l'amour au coeur des polémiques on
s'en souvient que les gens s'en souvient
lors du déplacement pendant la pandémie
et il était encore là il tient et
d'ailleurs gérald darmanin lors de la
conférence de presse lundi là clairement
défendu oui oui il commet disait il ne
remet pas en cause le nid le dispositif
de sécurité ni la manière dont la
sécurité a été a été menée samedi soir
alors évidemment ça fait réagir parce
qu'avec la réseau avec les réseaux
sociaux il ya des images qui circulent
et il ya des images qui parfois earth
certaines personnes qui sont surprise de
voir de voir certaines méthodes
employées mais à ce stade en tout cas
c'est vrai que didier lallement n'est
pas n'est pas critiquer ouvertement en
tout cas par gérald darmanin 16h58
normalement dans deux minutes début des
ascensions c'est gérald darmanin et
amélie oudéa castéra
par le sénat donc on attendait des
réponses évidemment le sénat attend des
réponses à ce qu'il y en aura plus que
d'habitude on surveillera surtout le
changement de ton par ce qu'il se dit
que
et bien emmanuel macron aurait un petit
peu taper sur les doigts de gérald
darmanin concernant son attitude on
continue à évoquer les questions qui
seront posées
normalement et on n'en doute pas une
seconde à gérald darmanin entre les
responsabilités donc on a parlé des
phobies on a parlé de l'organisation et
gérald darmanin insiste sur ses
supporters anglais a contrario il le ne
parle pas vraiment des jeunes
délinquants de ça ce sera une des
questions centrales mais ce sera une
question d'autant plus central qu'elle
est qu'elle est un petit peu utilisée
aussi politiquement les opposants de
droite ne cesse de mettre alors de la
droite à la fois les républicains et
aussi de la droite nationaliste
notamment à travers la voix de marine le
pen et du rassemblement national qui eux
évoquent les voyous les délinquants de
seine-saint-denis dont on voudrait terre
les actes et évidemment ça interroge les
opposants se demande si c'est là une
sorte de calcul électoral ou
électoralistes parce qu'on sait qu'on
est aussi en campagne des législatives
que que jean luc mélenchon a fait une
union de la gauche qui peut faire peur
parfois la majorité et que les quartiers
populaires votent en grande partie jean
luc mélenchon donc forcément il ya des
questionnements ça c'est une question
qui arrivent là on est clairement dans
de la politique est ce qu'on s'inquiète
pour les législatives parce que ça
commence à s'accumuler en douze jours un
la féra bad qui est vraisemblablement
pas fini même si le soufflé est un peu
retombé parce que les évènements
s'enchaînent et que finalement la
polémique du moment ce sont ces
événements de samedi soir au stade de
france ces événements
et un président à ces absents finalement
alors ça c'est jamais vu que le
président en place depuis que les
élections législatives sont après
l'élection présidentielle s'est jamais
vu qu'un président n'est pas une
majorité après c'est jamais bon en
campagne électorale évidemment d'avoir
une succession de polémiques de cette
manière surtout quand le terrain est
assez peu occupé par par le président
lui-même par les ministres qui sont en
période de réserve et puis tout ça ça
laisse de la place aux opposants parce
que en attendant les opposants défilent
dans les médias pour pointé des lacunes
sur la sécurité pour ce qui est des
opposants droite et puis la gauche se
plaint de l'airé de l'irresponsabilité
de ce gouvernement là bas ce qui tombe
beaucoup aussi c'est darmanin menteur
c'est jordan bardella le président par
intérim du rassemblement national l'a
quand même qualifié de menteur
pathologique donc on est dans des termes
très bon centreur trop fort bien sûr et
alors chacun est dans son rôle mais
forcément en campagne ça fait tâche et
puis et puis surtout on n'a pas
l'impression qu'elle est en campagne
cette majorité en fait c'est lé plus
occupées par les polémiques que par la
campagne électorale je note ce que me
dit polémiste paul emilie pseudo est
rigolo sur lefigaro.fr qui nous digérons
que j'habite à l'étranger voilà et dit
dimanche il le rappelle élections
législatives évidemment et alex 87 qui
nous dit au passage ce genre d'affaires
comme benalla etc montrent qu'une
chambre comme le sénat a toute son
utilité
démocratique voilà c'est ce qu'on nous
dit alors en jeu évidemment les
organisations de la coupe du monde de
rugby l'année prochaine mais et des jeux
olympiques enjeu immense il faut surtout
pas passer pour des pitres là et donc il
faut des réponses et c'est surtout ça
j'ai l'impression que le sénat a tant
fait oui évidemment parce que parce que
peu importe de quel bord politique on
est on veut tous que la france rayonne à
travers de tels événements sportifs
c'est les jeux olympiques la coupe du
monde c'est la vitrine d'un pays s'est
montrée c'est du tourisme ces apparences
et amener des gens dans dans le pays et
puis surtout c'est donner une image de
la france et cette image il faut qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient à la hauteur de ces
jeux donc c'est vrai que ça questionne
parce que là la presse européenne mais
aussi international a vu ce qui s'est
passé samedi soir puisque c'était
c'était un match qui a impliqué le real
madrid et liverpool donc
deux équipes
du sport le président attend évidemment
le plus oui il lui beaucoup de force
entre vous avez raison tient le plus à
voir
et il ya en tout cas c'est vrai que là
ce qu'il ya quand même la bri la presse
britannique qui a mis en une dans
certains magazines l'action de la france
en la dénonçant donc c'est quand même au
niveau de l'image du pays c'est très
négatif et on sait que que le sport
c'est vraiment un outil de rayonnement
qui est extrêmement important alors
sachez quand même que ce midi à l'issue
du conseil des ministres lors du
compte-rendu olivier grégoire la porte
parole a annoncé qu'un rapport était
attendu le 30 juin pour tirer les
conséquences en vue des jeux olympiques
voilà on attend ce rapport le 30 juin et
on surveillera ça évidemment 17h03 vous
savez quoi ils sont en retard voilà ça y
est c'est fait gérald darmanin et amélie
oudéa castéra ne sont pas au sénat pour
l'instant mais en tout cas il nous cette
audition n'a n'a pas commencé vous êtes
avec nous vous êtes de plus en prenons
plus nombreux à nous rejoindre vous le
disiez un ces auditions dont les a
découverts avec alexandre benalla et
maintenant les français comprennent que
c'est un moment important oui c'est ça
le le sénat c'est un peu révélé pendant
la sphère benalla parce que c'était un
an après l'élection d' emmanuel macron
elle était 2018 ça a été très très
faible taux n'est politiquement c'est
une affaire qu'on a découverte en oui en
plusieurs chapitres jeu senna est
souvent remis en cause on se le demande
à quoi sert le sénat parfois et là on le
voit le sénat en plus de voter les lois
à un vrai un vrai devoir d une vraie
compétence dax de contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement est en effet pendant la
sphère benalla et c'était un peu révélé
tout le monde tout le monde avait
regardé ces auditions au sénat je pense
que beaucoup de français avaient
découvert que le sénat auditionné je
pense que c'est parce qu'on fait tous
les jours deux allumer sa télé bien
regarder les sessions qui se déroulent
au sénat donc maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus connu est en effet les sénateurs et
puis cette majorité de droite qui
position de rien sur donc le sénat c'est
aussi c'est aussi un outil une chambre
qui est aux mains de l'opposition donc
forcément elle existe politiquement et
c'est son rôle machar dina vous ne
convaincrez pas tout le monde 58 qui me
disent sur lefigaro.fr rien ne changera
c'est une illusion démocratique
et oui peut-être ça c'est la question à
quoi à quoi ça sert après qu'est ce
qu'il va se passer alors que je crois
qu'on commence à voir des images qui
nous arrive je vais demander à rafah la
drague quitte en régie nous nous les
montre et n'ont cessé avec la sp oui
parce que c'est la sp qui nous envoie
ses images évidemment des premières
images de cette salle d'audition au
sénat on va voir ça dans un instant vous
les voyez le sénat est prêt et je crois
que gérald darmanin état si vous le
voyez au premier rang on attend le début
de ces de ses auditions ça commence dans
un instant oui dites moi alors on les
écoute et après le sénat qu'est ce
qu'ils en font de ces réponses et bien
selon peut-être que déjà ça va éclaircir
des choses
selon ce que les que les ministres et
les vont dire aux sénateurs est ce que
les sénateurs vont poser comme question
si on se rend compte que la version est
différente de ce qui a été dit ces
derniers jours ça va changer quelque
chose les sénateurs peuvent aussi
transmettre des informations recueillies
à la justice et puis ça peut déboucher
sur une commission d' enquête
parlementaire et puis surtout vraiment
j'insiste comme sur la culture alors
écoutons m
et bien sûr merci beaucoup voyez ça
commence à les six minutes de retard
c'est pas trop mal on écoute dont la
fonction de gérald darmanin et de la
ministre des sports a médité à castéra
ça devrait durer un peu plus de deux
heures vous restez avec nous sur youtube
sur lefigaro.fr sur twitch merci dina de
toutes ces précisions qu'est ce que l'on
écoute que cette commission et après on
se suit sur junior live à tout à vous
exprimer et puis ensuite
chacun des collègues parlementaires
présents ou en visioconférence se
signalant par avance eux pourra
poser des questions qu'ils souhaitent en
indiquant la règle du jeu habituel c'est
que deux minutes par question et par
intervention nous paraissent un temps
suffisant pour pouvoir formuler les
questions que vous souhaitez
samedi soir dernier de graves incidents
qui n'ont heureusement pas fait de
blessés graves se sont produits en marge
du match de la finale de la ligue des
champions qui opposait au stade de
france les équipes de liverpool et du
real de madrid
la gestion de cet événement a été
unanimement qualifiée
soit de scandaleuse voire même par
certains responsables politiques de
honte nationale
c'est donc à la fois pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé pour démêler les
responsabilités des différents
intervenants et pour tirer les
enseignements qui s'imposent de cet
événement afin que de tels incidents ne
se reproduisent plus que mon collègue
laurent lafon président la culture la
culture et moi même avons souhaité
conjointement vous entendre
vous vous êtes tous deux exprimé
publiquement
mais
les explications fournies font encore
aujourd'hui l'objet de critiques fortes
notamment de la part de personnes qui
étaient présentes sur les lieux
premier point concernant les causes des
incidents vous avez a indiqué incriminé
dès samedi soir je vous cite des
milliers de supporters britanniques sans
billet ou avec de faux billets auraient
forcé les entrées et parfois violente et
les stadiers
les responsabilités imputée aux
supporters britanniques ou la
responsabilité pardon imputée aux
supporters britanniques est toutefois
contestée notamment par les officiers de
la police de liverpool qui étaient
présents sur place comme observateurs
nombre d'observateurs ont noté au
contraire le calme de ces supporters qui
auraient contribué à l'absence
d'incident grave les services de
renseignements de la préfecture avait
t-il de ce point de vue là mal apprécié
ce que serait l'attitude de ses
supporters
vous avez également tous deux évoqué un
phénomène massif de faux billets de
l'ordre de 30000 à 40000
depuis leur le f a indiqué que seuls
deux mille huit cents billets avaient
été identifiés comme falsifiés lors du
passage des portiques ce chiffre pouvant
d'ailleurs être gonflé par des problèmes
techniques
comment ces fraudes qui serait donc bien
plus limité qu'annoncé en tous les cas
selon l'uefa aurait-elle pu jouer le
rôle déterminant que vous leur prêtez
dans les incidents de samedi soir
par ailleurs la presse s'est fait l'écho
d'une note durance et de renseignement
de la division nationale de lutte contre
le hooliganisme vous alertant dès le
mercredi 25 mai sur de possibles risques
liés à des billets falsifiés et la
présence de nombreux supporters sans
bruit sans billet
cette alerte at elle été dûment prises
en compte
encore été évoqué la gestion du prêt
filtrage à l'arrivée du rer d et
notamment des fils en nombre insuffisant
et un manque de personnel alors que
d'après ce que rapportent les médias le
dispositif était fluide à la sortie du
rer b qui étaient en grève ce jour là
il ne s'agissait pas d'une circonstance
imprévue les organisations syndicales de
la ligne b avait fait état dès le mardi
24 mai de leur intention de perturber le
déroulement de la finale de la ligue des
champions en cessant le travail
dans ces conditions comment expliquer
que le dispositif n'est pas été adapté
en conséquence est que les moyens n'est
pas été redéployée à la sortie du rer d
d'où semble-t-il sont douces ont
semble-t-il arriver une majorité de
spectateurs enfin l'intrusion de
riverains du stade de france a également
été évoquée tout comme des agressions et
des vols de spectateurs à la fin du
match sans qu'on en sache davantage à ce
stade
pouvez vous préciser le nombre
d'arrestations de poursuite de plaintes
liées à cet événement donc de procédure
engagée et qu'elle a été la suite donnée
à ces procédures
la plupart des personnes arrêtées
auraient été je pose la question des
sans-papiers est-ce le cas et comment
l'expliquez vous le deuxième point la
question se pose de la responsabilité
des différents intervenants et notamment
des services placés sous la route
responsabilité le rapport qui a été
adressée par le préfet de police à qui
vous a été adressée par le préfet de
police au soir du 29 mai semble exonérer
la police de toute responsabilité
l'organisation de la ligue des champions
relève de la responsabilité de l'uefa
mais c'est bien sûr celle de la
préfecture de police qui est pointé du
doigt notamment par son usage qui aurait
été qualifié de massifs et d'incriminer
des gaz lacrymogènes qui aurait touché
des familles des enfants les personnes
de bonne foi munis de billets valides et
qui pour certaines d'entre elles n'ont
jamais pu entrer dans le stade
il est essentiel que vous nous apportiez
des explications circonstanciées sur le
schéma d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui avaient été retenus pour cet
événement et notamment et notamment
sur les consignes qui ont été données
aux forces en matière d' usage des gaz
lacrymogènes et la répartition des
missions entre les agents de la
direction de la sécurité publique et les
unités de forces mobiles
la presse s'est également fait l'écho du
fait que la doctrine d'usagé en la
matière pourrait être modifiée en
prévision des grands événements sportifs
à venir nous les connaissons tous ils
seront importants l'année prochaine et
l'année suivante est ce le cas
enfin il est également il a également
été rapportée par un certain nombre de
journalistes que ceux ci avaient été
contraints de supprimer des images
qu'ils avaient prises des événements
ces faits sont avérés
des consignes en ce sens sont
effectivement donné aux forces de
l'ordre cet été le cas comment les
justifier
enfin s'agissant notamment de
l'intrusion de riverains de jeunes
riverains et des exactions qu'ils
auraient commises à l'issue du match
comment expliquer que ceux ci n'ait pas
été repéré en amont par les forces de
police et que des dispositions
particulières n'est pas été prises pour
sécuriser la sortie du stade à la fin de
celui-ci
enfin la france a déjà par le passé
accueilli des manifestations sportives
de cette ampleur sans qu'elle de lieux
d'ailleurs aux débordements dont
malheureusement le monde entier a été
témoin samedi soir
nous nous interrogeons et c'est pour ça
que nous sommes ici cet après midi sur
cette situation sur la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé d'abord pour savoir
effectivement et comprendre ces
événements en tirer les conséquences
nécessaires évidemment mais aussi parce
que dans quelque temps en quelques mois
notre pays organisera accueillera la
coupe du monde de rugby en 2023 et par
ailleurs en 2024 et jeux olympiques et
les jeux paralympiques
voilà mal lui je me suis le ministre
chers collègues les propos introductifs
je vais délaisser la parole tout de
suite au président laurent lafon
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord je suis désolé de ne pas être
parmi vous mais je suis contre un
isolement suite un test positif je vous
remercie à mon tour pour leur présence
cet après midi au sénat ne sut gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur et
madame amélie oudéa castéra ministre des
sports et des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
je ne doute pas madame la ministre que
nous aurons prochainement l'occasion de
nous revoir pour examiner plus à fond
l'ensemble des dossiers qui relèvent de
votre ministère mais je saisis cette
occasion puisque je crois que c'est
votre première venue au sénat en tout
cas dans le cadre de vos nouvelles
fonctions pour vous féliciter pour votre
nomination comme l'a indiqué le
président de la commission des lois la
gravité des dysfonctionnements se sont
déroulées samedi à proximité immédiate
de paris et dans le futur stade
olympique ne pouvait nous laisser
indifférent une compétition prestigieuse
entaché des milliers de personnes
retarder ou empêcher d'accéder au stade
certaines molesté des actes de
délinquance en grand nombre le sénat se
devait d'exercer son pouvoir de contrôle
devant ce que l'on peut qualifier de
fiasco deux ans avant les jeux
olympiques et un an avant la coupe du
monde de rugby
nous avons de nombreuses questions à
vous poser
comme a commencé à le faire le président
buffet parmi lesquels à mon sens une
s'impose ces incidents était-il
prévisible et donc évitables il est
important pour nous de savoir la nature
des échanges et des décisions
éventuelles prises par les différentes
autorités et à l'effort consortium du
stade de france ra tp sncf avant la
finale alors que vous saviez depuis
plusieurs jours que deux événements
allaient fortement impacté
l'organisation du match la grève sur le
rer b connue depuis plusieurs jours et
la france billetterie identifiés par la
division nationale de la lutte contre le
hooliganisme dans une note en date du 25
mai soit trois jours avant la finale je
rappelle que le 13 novembre 2021 à peine
six mois le match france- kazakhstan
dans le cadre des éliminatoires de la
coupe du monde avait été dès l'école est
délocalisée au parc des princes car des
travaux étaient programmés sur la ligne
b du rer
les risques de saturation d autres
moyens de transport et en particulier de
la ligne d avait été considéré comme
trop important à l'époque
allait pas encore la grève de la ratp
sur cette même ligne a eu des effets
similaires à ce qui était redouté à
l'automne dernier avec des rapports très
important sur la ligne d du rer est ce
que l'hypothèse d'un report de la finale
a été envisagée compte tenu de la grève
annoncée est ce que le risque de
saturation a été suffisamment évalués à
défaut de pouvoir reporter la rencontre
des mesures exceptionnelles ont elles
été envisagée comme par exemple la
réquisition de conducteur sur la ligne b
la régulation des flux en amont de la
ligne d un paris nord où la mise en
place d'un système de transport
alternatif par bus comment avez vous
essayé de prévenir ce risque prévisible
de saturation
concernant l'accès au stade de france
ensuite vous avez indiqué que de
nombreux faux billets avaient été
diffusées et que c'est le club de
liverpool qui avait demandé
l'établissement de billets papier que
vous avez estimé aisément falsifiable ma
question est donc la suivante qu'elles
ont été la nature de vos échanges avec
l'uefa sur ce point et pourquoi ne pas
avoir exigé de l'uefa l'établissement
des billets électroniques un falsifiable
là encore le risque était identifiée et
rien pourtant ne semble avoir été fait
pour les éviter je laisserai mes
collègues vous poser d'autres questions
mais je ne serait éludée l'inquiétude
qu'a suscitée
chez nombre de sénateurs cet échec de
samedi dernier quant à l'organisation
des jeux olympiques à paris en 2024
quelle leçon allez vous retirer
le organiser la finale de la champion s
league un an avant la coupe du monde de
rugby et deux ans avant les jeux
olympiques avaient valeur de test le
test montre que manifestement ne sommes
pas encore prêts à faire face à toutes
les situations
l'originalité revendiquer des jeux de
paris tient au fait que l'événement
devrait être autant dans les stades que
dans les vues avec un immense
rassemblement populaire je pense en
particulier à la cérémonie d'ouverture
qui doit rassembler plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes le long de la
seine n'est-il pas nécessaire compte
tenu des événements de samedi dernier de
réfléchir l'informa pas plus raisonnable
pour éviter un nouveau fiasco qui
nuirait à l'image de notre pays mesdames
messieurs les ministres je vous sais de
la parole enfin si le président du fai
botha reprend la parole peut être que on
peut transmettre tout de suite le la
parole au ministre
celui-ci vous en prie
madame la ministre cheikh hamidi
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ne se présente la commission
des affaires culturelles mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'est avec le souci de la transparence
et du sens des responsabilités que nous
vous présentons devant vous avec le
profond respect pour la représentation
nationale et ses prérogatives et un
gouvernement qui n'a rien à cacher et
nous nous réjouissons du pouvoir qu'ils
nous aient laissé c'est à dire du temps
nécessaire pour expliquer ce qui s'est
passé samedi soir lors du match de
finale de ligue des champions qui
opposait real madrid liverpool nous
étions d'ailleurs tous les deux madame
la ministre et moi-même il est évident
que cette fête du sport a été gâchée et
que nous regrettons très sincèrement les
débordements
parfois inacceptables qui ont eu lieu
dont nous allons en assurant notre
responsabilité explicite est devant vous
le déroulement j'espère me se présente
la commission des lois se présenter
comme 15 affaires culturelles répondre
aux questions en tout cas nous allons
nous répartir évidemment ces questions
introductive
dans la présentation que je vais vous
faire dans quelques instants dont je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté d'ailleurs
qu'elle soit faite devant les sénateurs
je veux aussi dire que pour ceux qui
nous regardent sera sur les réseaux
sociaux pour ceux qui le souhaitent il
était guide également évident que pour
les fans de football dont nous sommes un
certain nombre et pour avoir été arbitre
de football pendant de très nombreuses
années l'image négative de ce match est
une blessure pour notre fierté nationale
il est évident que les choses auraient
pu être mieux organisé
avant nous éviter le pire oui pouvons
nous mieux organisés à vaulruz aurions
nous pu anticiper davantage sans doute
responsable de mon administration je
regrette très sincèrement les attaques
dont était la cible les fonctionnaires
de la république qui sont sous ma
responsabilité
comme ministre il est tout à fait normal
que je réponde aux médias parlementaire
à la critique de l'opinion et seuls les
lâche je crois se défausse sur leurs
subordonnés je veux donc ici dire la
confiance que l'ensemble des personnes
que j'ai l'honneur de commander depuis
deux ans ministère de l'intérieur et
complète pour ma part
comme le disait le président mitterrand
signé point d'honneur sans
difficulté je suis devant vous
évidemment que la ministre des sports
pour pouvoir détailler cette soirée si
vous me permettez voyons déjà le
contexte général qui a évoqué notamment
monsieur président de la commission des
affaires culturelles je voudrais ici
rappeler qu'un ministre des sports que
la finale de la champions league devait
se dérouler à saint pétersbourg et que
suite à la situation géopolitique a été
décidé de la situer dans un autre stade
la france était candidate pour
accueillir cette champions league dont
je rappelle et vous l'avez dit monsieur
présidents des commissions des lois que
l'organisation de cet événement en
revient à l'uefa et à la fédération
nationale la fédération française de
football
normalement dans les finales tels que
sap et hambourg aurait dû organiser ces
18 mois en général pour le cahier des
charges les réunions publiques
organisées une tête final la france y
compris les pouvoirs publics bien
évidemment et en lien avec la fédération
française et uefa a organisé cette
manifestation en trois mois de plus vous
l'avez dit une grève ratp quelques jours
auparavant a été annoncé qui a déplacé
massivement les supporters des lignes du
rer b vers le rer d je veux aussi dire
que la difficulté principale que nous
ayons eu le premier enchaînement négatif
de cette soirée fait que le flux sur le
rer d a été 3 5 fois plus important
selon les chiffres de la sncf que lors
d'un match de football qui amène du
monde à le stade de france on va dire de
façon normale prenons comme étalon
quelques jours auparavant la finale de
la coupe de france qui pourtant
d'ailleurs a été classé de manière plus
négative par les services de lutte
contre le hooliganisme que la finale de
champions league puisque vous parlez des
notes de renseignements aux sportifs du
ministère de l'intérieur et pour ceux
qui ont pris le rrd le rer b pour aller
au stade de france chacun s'apercevra
que le rer b effet si je dire pour ça
avec une plus grande sortie plusieurs
sorties et un plus grand espace pour
accéder au stade de france et que le r
vrd et plus étroit avec un goulot
d'étranglement en dessous de l'autoroute
qui amène directement effectivement au
stade de france singulièrement pour les
tribunes britannique car nous verrons
que les débordements et les difficultés
dans le lieu que devant les tribunaux
britanniques
quel était le dispositif de sécurité est
question première que vous m'avez posé
monsieur le président il ya eu six mille
huit cents policiers et gendarmes et
quelques dizaines de satan pompiers
déployés pour assurer la sécurité de
l'événement c'est l'événement qui depuis
je suis mise à l'intérieur événement
sportif bien évidemment à mobiliser le
plus de policiers et de gendarmes parmi
ceux ci il ya eu des ce qu'on appelle
les ufr les unités de forces mobiles à
peu près 80 crs ou gendarmes mobiles qui
ont été prédisposés dans le périmètre du
stade de france 18 fm on reverra le fait
que ce jamais de cette de france en tout
cas depuis le semi l'intérieur d'un
inconnu autant je rappelle que suite à
la note de renseignement justement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois qui prévoyait à très nombreux
nombre d'anglais sans ticket ou quelques
centaines avec des faux billets nous y
reviendrons plus tous ceux qui
viendraient à paris pour pouvoir
supporter leur équipe le support
l'entraîneur du club de liverpool ayant
dit lui-même qu'il fallait en grand
nombre venir même sans billet appareils
supportés liverpool a été décidé d'eux
fan zones l'une cours de vincennes très
éloignées donc du stade de france où il
ya eu jusqu'à 40000 personnes
essentiellement des supporters anglais
ou des supporters du club de liverpool
il peut y avoir des français qui sont
allés dans 700 tonnes bien évidemment et
puis un qui est juste à côté du stade de
france la fan zone euro pourraient
appeler real madrid qui était à saint
denis j'aurais d'ailleurs dire ici que
les deux faces zones qui ont accueillis
à partir de 14 heures quasiment plus de
50000 personnes n'ont fait l'objet
d'aucun débat redemande majeur et n'ont
pas causé de difficultés particulières
il y avait également la sécurisation de
l'aéroport charles de gaulle puisque
l'essentiel des espagnols sont arrivés
notamment par des avions affrétés ce qui
n'a pas été le cas le cas pardon des
supporters anglais des sites sensibles
puisque paul nizon l'intérieur et préfet
de police des champs-elysées sont
toujours les lieux des rendez-vous ou
des supporters quels que soient leur
équipe d'ailleurs allié à peut-être des
personnes qui voudraient procuré une
joie dans la délinquance pourrait se
donner rendez vous sur les champs
elysées malheureusement notre pays on
est souvent témoin 4e ont été
prédisposés une nuit fm dans paris qui
faisait la nuit des réserves notamment
dans les gares puisque beaucoup de gens
est notamment arrivé par la gare de du
nord pour l'ombre étaient présents et la
gestion des flux de voyageurs évidemment
à partir de chats tva les nations qui
sont nos deux grandes gares et robert
qui amène de plus de monde au stade de
france sur la seine saint denis en
particulier et là je veux répondre
directement aux questions monsieur
présent la commission des lois et les
320si effectifs de sécurité publique à
ne pas confondre avec quasiment 6000
effectifs d'ordre public on verra sans
doute que ces êtres différents ce qui
est une des difficultés que nous avons
connues gevrey comparer les 326
effectifs de policiers en tenue et en
civil ou en bac qui étaient autour du
stade de france aux 164 qui étaient là
pour la finale de coupe de france c'est
à dire que nous avons doublé en
prévision de ce match qu'ils avaient
pourtant le même nombre de spectateurs a
priori le nombre d'effectifs en ordre
public et en sécurité publique dans
paris dans les fan zone qui n'existait
pas par groupe de france mais surtout
autour du stade donc pour répondre
concrètement votre question il y avait
très largement assez d'effectifs de
police pour cet événement
qui était attendue depuis effectivement
plusieurs semaines alors le déroulé
précis de la soirée se passe ainsi à
partir de 18h45 il ya beaucoup de
spectateurs qui arrivent auparavant mais
comme cela se passe sans problème je n'y
reviens pas il ya eu une bagarre sur le
barrage la passerelle de les cluses et
deux tentatives d'intrusion dans un
parking vers ip et dans le village
l'uefa qui étaient situées au nord entre
la fan zone espagnol finalement et le
stade de france très vite la police est
intervenue pour faire cesser les
troubles 13 individus ont été
interpellés notamment des individus qui
ont essayé d'entrer dans le parking vip
et qui se situe et on voit le petit
terrain de football la tout honneur du
stade de france à peu près ici jusqu'à
18h45 parallèlement les arrivées sont
importantes mais pour la police mais
prix maîtrisés des spectateurs dans un
contexte très difficile liée à la grève
du rer b cela a conduit énormément de
monde donc à prendre soin la ligne 13
qui a trois stations de métro qui arrive
au stade de france ça se passera de
façon tout à fait nominal et sans aucune
difficulté y compris dans les accès au
stade de france et effectivement le rer
d dont j'ai évoqué l'étroitesse de la
sortie
de 19h à 20h45 là est le noeud du
problème
les pressions sont très importante
exercée par plusieurs milliers de
supporters et la préfecture de police
compte jusqu'à 15000 personnes dans le
goulot étroit qui le séparent de la
sortie du rer d qui prend la nuit sonne
on verra tout à l'heure la l'artère pour
arriver au pré filtrage et là c'est un
point très important qui explique la
difficulté de la soirée le stade de
france a décidé depuis la coupe de
france c'est à dire depuis seulement une
semaine devant un certain nombre de
difficultés qu'il a pu connaître et pour
expérimenter notamment prévision de la
coupe du monde de rugby un nouveau
filtrage de mettre des stadiers qui
était d'ailleurs plus en grand nombre
cette fois-ci kader x 1600 stadiers pour
ce match 1300 pour la finale de coupe de
france pour le nombre de spectateurs
laisse à des contrôles de près filtrage
à l'entrée
bien en amont du maï du stade de france
c'est la deuxième fois que le stade de
france se faisait la première fois
c'était passé sans encombre la coupe de
france la deuxième fois donc on
contrôler les billets pour ceux qui
portaient des billets bien en amont à la
sorte il a quasiment du rer d dans
l'entrée
du périmètre du stade de france je
voudrais aussi dire que ce n'est pas les
services de police qui contrôle les
billets je sais que c'est entendu mais
comme je lis parfois des choses un peu
erronée je veux le dire ici en revanche
les gendarmes mobiles et des crs en
l'occurrence là les gendarmes mobiles
sont à l'appui des stadiers afin de ne
pas laisser passer des gens qui
n'auraient pas de billet ou que ces
billets seraient faux d'autres que nous
le sans doute la fédération française de
football pourrait vous dire que dans les
billets effectivement le club de
liverpool a demandé que l'intégralité de
ces billets ont été en papier
tous les matchs qui se sont déroulés par
la championne tigres jusqu'à la finale
les billets électroniques la demande de
liverpool a été papier les 20000
supporters anglais qui avaient le droit
comme les 20000 madrilène as des billets
ont demandé par billet papier le club
madrilène la ministre reviendra d'en
demander beaucoup moins mais comme
liverpool l'intégralité j'ai ici je vous
laisserais bien évidemment un vrai
ticket est un faux tickets le coupon
pardon est parti il ya derrière les
tickets forêt ou faux un petit carré et
les stadiers du stade de france ont un
stylo chimique qui permet de raturer
pourvoir selon la couleur est ce que ce
billet vrai ou est-ce que ce billet est
faux parce que malheureusement la
technique des faux billets très lucratif
a déjà été éprouvée si j'ose dire
notamment d'angleterre mais pas
seulement en angleterre et il s'est
trouvé que dans ce premier prêt filtrage
que nous on a appliqué que la stade de
france pardon à appliquer partout sur
toutes les entrées du stade de france
seule l'entrée du rer d qui a mené le
plus évidemment de supporters anglais
dans les virages britannique qu'on verra
au sud on va vous avez un petit peu trop
vite qui peut juste avant
on poser des problèmes et d'après les
équipes de la fédération française de
football et du stade de france plus de
50 % des billets entre 57 et 70% selon
les entrées étaient faux ça ne veut pas
dire que tous les supporters avaient des
billets faut il ya eu beaucoup de
supporters qui n'avaient également pas
billets parce qu'ils ont essayé de
s'approcher du stade de france pour
diverses raisons qui leur appartiennent
et puis dans ce public elle aussi des
personnes qui avaient des billets et
c'est à bon compte sans doute qu'une
partie des gens qui ont des faux billets
pense que ce sont des vrais ils sont
très difficilement reconnaissables vous
les verrez
mais il ya eu deux types de fraudes que
nous avons totalement caractérise et qui
fait l'objet de l'article 40 qui a fait
le préfet de police à ma demande et
l'ouverture immédiate d'une enquête par
le parquet de bobigny le premier type de
fraude qu'on avait caractérisé ces des
personnes qui ont acheté des billets
qu'on savait à peu près fausse va venir
assez efficace parce qu'on les a achetés
à la sauvette que ce soit en angleterre
ou à paris pour 50 livres chacun et ça
permettait en tout cas avant qu'on ne
sache qui est des prêts filtrage aux
sans doute quand on était un supporteur
britannique de pouvoir passer d'accéder
dans les grilles du stade de france
puisque ensuite après ce pré filtrage il
y a le tourniquet qui lui prévoient la
lecture qr codes de ce ticket et puis il
ya ceux qui sans doute ont acheté un
deuxième type de fraude
peut-être si je dis en toute honnêteté
avec des billets qui se sont vendus
entre 800 et 1200 euros dans des faux
sites ou dans des endroits on a vendu
des billets papier en faisant croire que
c'était des vrais billets
je vous donne un exemple il ya parfois
des bars on en vend ses billets
officielle parce que c'est un
partenariat on connaît sans doute ça
dans nos propres commune hélas ces
tickets très cher qui ressemble vraiment
exactement au premier on verra
d'ailleurs ce qui explique les chiffres
de l'uefa dès 2700 fatigués qu'ils ont
compté eux c'est sans doute des vrais
faux billets dont les gens ont cru très
certainement encore aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient des vrais billets mais dont l
enquête montrera sans difficulté qu'ils
étaient des faux donc on a eu beaucoup
de monde hier vers détroit frémit de
plus du fait d'une part de la grève du
rer b et du fait on le verra aussi du
nombre très important de supporters ou
de spectateurs au dessus des 75 mille
personnes qui accueillent naturellement
vraiment le stade de france arrivé à ce
prêt filtrage dans un endroit déjà
extrêmement étroits la masse des
personnes qui ne pouvaient pas passer
puisqu'il y avait énormément de
s'oublier constaté par les stadiers du
stade de france s'accumuler et devant
cette accumulation évidemment il ya eu
un certain nombre de débordements qui a
constaté la préfecture de police vous
avez sur le côté droit des tweets qui
relève de nos amis de nos amis ou des
constats britannique des faux billets en
vente notamment là c'est sur twitter le
les réseaux sociaux en sont pleins je
voudrais dire que côté espagnol il y
avait même nombre de spectateurs aucun
problème aucun constat de faux billets
et durs sas et 20000 espagnol 20000
anglais et à tous les autres tous ceux
qui ont acheté des billets c'est choisir
en france qui sont venus sans supporter
particulièrement à les clubs de
liverpool real madrid ont pu rentrer
sans aucun problème ni de faux tickets
ni d'ordre public ni de près filtrage
le premier problème et on y reviendra
parce que c'est ce qui a créé évidemment
la grande confusion que l'on a connu le
premier problème a été renforcée par le
deuxième problème c'est à dire après le
prêt filtrage puisqu'on a levé ce prêt
filtrage pour des questions d'ordre
public on y reviendra ce son côté des
virages britannique les citoyens
britanniques ou supporters de l'équipe
de liverpool qui sont présentés dans les
tourniquets on a passé le qr code et là
nous avons effectivement d'après des
chiffres de l'unef et nous avons les
mêmes chiffres que l'uefa de 1889 faux
billets qui ont été scannées au tripode
c'est évidemment les machines qui
permettent de passer alors plusieurs
billets ont été dupliqués des centaines
de fois par le prestataire donc c'est
les chiffres du prestataire orange qui a
mis à connectique des portiques de
sécurité du stade de france un même
billet c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a
acheté un billet officiel a été parfois
dupliquer pour la 760 fois avec le même
numéro vous avez évidemment des numéros
là votre place dans le stade votre rang
dans le stade enfin chacun voit ce
qu'est habillé de football ou
d'événements sportifs un autre 744 fois
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont
acheté des billets et comme de vrais
faussaires ils ont reproduit ces billets
pour les vendre eux-mêmes et évidemment
ils ont reproduit des numéros qui
existait vraiment mais au lieu qu'ils
existent qu une seule fois il ya des
gens qui ont multiplié par 7 144 la
place qu'ils auraient dû avoir ce qui
fait que lorsque dans la confusion des
genres sont rentrés parfois dans le
stade sans contrôle parce qu'il y en a
eu quelques-uns quand même il ya des
témoignages d'ailleurs sur la zone
qu'ils disent mais moi j'ai le même
ticket que quelqu'un est donc je
m'assois voilà c'est une autre problème
qu'on a eu effectivement je voudrais
dire que tous les documents que je
présente monsieur présent j'en ai fait
une copie pour vous et pour monsieur
président de la commission des affaires
culturelles et évidemment je voulais
soin d'en distribuer si vous souhaitez
aux sénateurs ça nous vient directement
donc de la connectique or revenons à
notre premier problème près filtrage
puisqu'on à 15000 personnes autour de
19h30 qui s'agglutinent des femmes des
enfants évidemment des personnes qui
peuvent être en mobilité réduite qui
sont sous le tunnel de l'a86 au sud de
notre stade de france les virages et
clubs anglais sont dans les portes
notamment y z et à c'est à dire au
dessus des espagnols étant tout à
l'opposé est là devant le nombre très
important de personnes qui sont bloquées
et refoulé par les stadiers parce que on
considère qu'ils n'ont pas de bons
tickets le préfet de police prend la
décision de lever de près filtrage afin
d'éviter des écrasements et des
bousculades et je pense que c'est cette
décision monsieur le président de la
commission des lois qui à éviter des
drames humains qui auraient
malheureusement tout à fait pu arriver
et qui sont arrivés malheureusement dans
l'histoire du football et de les foules
en se présentant au tour des stats donc
à partir de ce moment 19h45 il n'y a
plus de pré filtrage les gendarmes
mobiles lève à la demande du préfet de
police de filtrage et des milliers de
personnes en l'occurrence 15000 mais il
ya plein de gens qui sortent du rrd je
rappelle qu à 10h45 nous sommes encore à
1h15 du coup d'envoi officiel se
présentent sur le match du stade de
france et se présente au gris et
notamment concentré dans les virages
anglais il n'y a pas de problème dans
les autres tribunes y ait des as qui
correspondent au sud du dispositif
les stadiers ne contrôle plus près
filtrage
évidemment non plus beaucoup évidemment
d'intérêt devant la confusion il ce
recul est désormais cette foule a accès
aux tourniquets d'accès c'est à dire là
où on a constaté par ailleurs les 2800
faux tickets par la signalétique orange
l'a évidemment devant le monde très
important et on peut estimer les
chiffres évidemment ne sont pas fiables
disait encore à cette heure mais à 5 à
6000 le nombre de gens qui poussent les
grilles de ces deux et trois portes et
notamment des portes d'urgence qui a 300
kg lâche et permettent de rentrer dans
le stade et c'est normal puisque c'est
la sécurité civile le préfet de police
prend une deuxième décision est de
rapatrier
l'ordre public les gendarmes mobiles qui
encadraient ces prêts filtrage et qui
encadraient les sorties du rer d qui est
assez longue quand vous regardez la
carte les reverra si vous le souhaitez
jusqu'aux tribunes pour mettre les
gendarmes de l'autre côté des grilles
pour éviter que des grilles ne lâche et
accessoirement éviter les intrusions
c'est sans doute ce qui évoquera les
questions de délinquance puisque sur ce
mail de cheminement entre la sortie du
rer d et le stade de france il n'y aura
plus ou beaucoup moins de forces de
police puisqu'ils sont tous rapatriés en
urgence devant le mouvement de foule
dans le stade pour soutenir si j'ose
dire les grilles et pour éviter les
intrusions et donc soit à l'écrasement
contre les grilles soit l'envahissement
du terrain ce qui aurait évidemment
empêché le match de se dérouler
une grande partie donc des far s'est
repositionnée je les dis et la laiterie
potes c'est à dire les tourniquets il
faut bien voir ce que ça veut dire sur
trois portes il y avait à peu près vingt
mille supporters anglais même de 1800
faux tickets c'est quand même plus de
10% des femmes il est donc quand vous
êtes on a vu tous des images parfois de
gens très connus dont le ticket semblait
ne pas marcher et qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils sont passés en dessous ils sont
passés au dessus et évidemment bout d'un
moment plus personne n'a mis son ticket
et a décidé de passer si je veux dire
comme dans un métro où tout le monde
frauderait de l'autre côté les effectifs
alors procèdent à des opérations de
maintien sur le mile donc c'est à dire
en dehors du stade de france pour
évincer les milliers d'individus et de
certains hostiles vous avez tout à fait
raison et on peut considérer qu'on ordre
public à partir de la fin de la première
mi temps il n'y a plus de difficulté ou
très accessoire sur le stade sur le
stade de france
l'évacuation a lors du match ce fait je
parle de la fin de seconde mi-temps sans
difficulté alors même que liverpool a
perdu comme chacun l'a vu pas de bagarre
pas d'envahissement de terrain et tout
le monde repart si j'ose dire prendre
ces transports avec de nouvelles
difficultés délinquance sur le mile
puisque l'ordre public n'est plus
rétabli entre les rer d et le stade de
france et je rappelle que les deux
femmes zone notamment celle qui comporte
quasiment quarante mille supporters le
cours de vincennes se fait dans des
conditions nominale à une exception près
de la nation ou le tenancier d'un
restaurant demande l'ordre public après
avoir eu son restaurant dévasté par des
supporters sans doute avinés alors le
point principal monsieur le président
puisque c'est votre question c'est
comment on arrive à 30 milles
trente mille personnes supplémentaires
des 75000 personnes du stade de france
je comprends bien que ce chiffre est
important on n'a jamais dit si vous me
le permettez avec un ministre des sports
que c'était 35 mille faux billets nous
avons toujours dit que c'était 30000 à
40000 personnes soit non porteurs de
billets soit ayant des faux billets qui
sera ajouté aux soixante quinze mille
personnes qui eux avaient un vrai billet
alors nous avons au moins de
possibilités de source pour ceux qui ne
croient pas la préfecture de police la
première peut-être c'est celle de la
fédération française de football qui
elle même communiqué officiellement vous
avez dû voir cela il ya soixante quinze
mille et non pas 80 mille billets édités
par la fédération c'est à dire par
l'organisateur l'uefa fff sur ces 75 les
personnes qui auraient dû se rendre au
stade de france malheureusement nous
avons constaté cent dix mille personnes
dans le stade de france et autour du
stade de france ayant emprunté les
transports ça se décompose comme suit 79
1200 personnes c'est à dire le plus déjà
de nombreux cas des billets qui ont pris
les transports en commun on a lignes de
rer vous le verrez par lignes de rer les
détails des personnes qui ont été
comptés on en remercie la ratp la sncf
21000 bus de très facile à savoir
puisque l'intégralité des supporters
espagnols organisé par leurs clubs sont
arrivés par des bus c'est le cas
seulement de 1/3 des supporters anglais
c'est aussi un de nos problèmes et puis
évidemment tous ceux qui sont arrivés en
véhicules particuliers 6000 taxi et
chauffeurs privés après avoir contacté
la fédération a contacté les sociétés de
taxis et les sociétés privées de
chauffeurs privés qui ont évidemment la
géo localisation de leurs courses et
4100 personnes avec un véhicule
particulier les parkings en font foi ce
qui veut dire vous avez le tableau
récapitulatif
que selon les chiffres donnés non pas
par nous mais par la ratp ou la sncf
attendait pour venir allez-y nous avons
exactement les mêmes chiffres à quelques
centaines ou aller moins de 5000 près
c'est tout à fait possible se rappelle
que je regrette personnellement que nous
n'ayons pas pu utiliser des drones pour
pouvoir mettre dans la gestion de la
foule plus de l'image sur nos sujets
mais nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler dans d'autres circonstances la
ligne 13 la ratp faisait naître 27000
personnes qui sont venues au stade de
france
le r vrd nord 37000 on voit bien là sur
représentation du rer d qui d'habitude
n'est pas celui qui accueille le plus de
personnes puisque celui là que le plus
de personnes c'est le rer b qui la
relève de la sncf je veux dire ici à
ceux qui pensent qu'il ya un problème de
chiffres entre nous que les rer b gare
du nord direct stade de france est gérée
par la sncf et que les chiffres ratp rer
b qui fait des stations si j'ose dire
normal et l'a gérée par la ratp ce qui
fait la différence des 6500 que l'on
voit parfois entre les deux comptages et
les 10500 donc gérée par la ratp henri
robert b ce qui nous fait donc un sou
total déjà de 80000 personnes qui se
rendent paraître transport public au
stade de france alors que le stade là
que 75 mille billets nous y rajoute ont
bien évidemment les taxis les taxis g7
les vtc de toutes sortes les gens qui
sont arrivés en car les gens qui sont
arrivés en bus des gens qui sont arrivés
en provenance de leurs propres véhicules
dans les parkings et donc nous obtenions
toussaint un chiffrage et entre 109
milles et 117 mille personnes
c'est-à-dire plus beaucoup plus de 30000
personnes 34800 sur la fourchette basse
quarante deux mille huit cents soit
fourchette haute c'est personnes soit
son entrée dans le stade de façon
numéraire à quelques centaines près sans
doute soit sont restées aux abords
immédiats du stade de france soit sont
allé un peu plus loin que les abords
immédiats de france sous l'effet de
l'ordre public mais aussi soudé fait
parfois des prêts filtrage puisque le
pré fit rage n'a pas fonctionné que dans
les portes sud de liverpool pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées et partout
ailleurs les gens n'ont pas pu accéder
au parvis du stade de france en ce
qu'ils avaient soit des faux billets
soient pas de billet du tout et puis il
ya un deuxième phénomène qui sans doute
a fait de gagner une partie des
supporters c'est que pour tous ceux qui
sont allés au stade de france la 4g
fonctionne mal et quand on ne rentre pas
dans un stade et qu'on veut regarder un
match et là on essaie de trouver quand
on est supporters par ailleurs la
captation de son téléphone donc ça a
sans doute encouragé on le reverra des
gens à partir très rapidement aussi
quand il aura pu rentrer dans le dans le
stade alors comment on peut dire que
parce que beaucoup jeudi les critiques
et 10 b d'accord très bien imaginer que
les 35000 personnes de plus mais ils
sont passés où ses trente cinq mille
personnes et bien la sncf a elle-même
documenté on vous a également fourni la
note qu'elle nous a fourni qu'à 22h52
c'est à dire au lendemain de la première
mi temps de très nombreux supporters ont
commencé à reprendre les métros et en
l'occurrence ici le rer d et donc
comment ça s'est passé il ya eu un
décalage une demi heure du coup d'envoi
on est passé de 21 heures à 21h30 21h30
22h15 première mi temps 22h15 22h30 mi
temps
22h30 et 23h15 fin du match et au moment
où la ratp sncf pour répondre à une
vocation de l'anticipation attend la fin
du match parce qu'on avait évidemment
décalé avec eux les lignes de rer après
le décalage du du coup de sifflet final
ce qui objectivement est une grande
prouesse de la part de la ratp sncf de
rappeler leurs conducteurs et leurs
trames le rame de métro dans des
contexte d'hyper urgence et bell ont
même dû anticiper cela puisque dès 22h45
22h52 nous dit la sncf mais les images
de vidéo protection que je ne peux pas
vous fournir pour des raisons de
protection des libertés mais qu' ils
sont à votre disposition je suis sûre
s'ils voulaient demander à qui de droit
dénonce que les quais du rer d notamment
de la plaine stade de france ont plein
plein de beaucoup de maillots rouges et
malheureusement la sncf doit refaire
venir très rapidement des trains et des
22h52 les trains repartent à paris dans
des conditions évidemment qui n'ont rien
à voir avec un match en mal tout le
monde attend en général la fin d'un
match lorsque ce match n'est pas infinie
alors j'ai aussi permis ça répondre à
votre question sur notamment la note de
l'adn et nash faire un comparatif avec
la finale de coupe de france que nous
avions organisée si j'ose dire quelques
jours auparavant ce match de coupe de
france c'était à priori d'après la dlna
ch plus dangereux que matches de
championnat 10 et chacun sait que
certains clubs de supporters des deux
clubs de football qui se sont opposés je
n'aurais pas faire d' insulte ici
particulière aux sénateurs élus de ces
départements poser des problèmes de
supportérisme comme on dit très
important et c'était déjà un match de
football que nous avions
particulièrement me
autour de l'ordre public et où s'est
déroulée très peu d'incidents il ya eu
plus de spectateurs que de billets
vendus pour la finale de coupe de france
que pour la chanteuse dit qu il y a eu
chacun le voit sur ce sur ce graphique
il ya eu 160 2 1 policiers engagés de
sécurité publique pour la coupe de
france 326 donc je les dis pour la
chanteuse dit il y avait 800 dix
policiers d'ordre public pour la coupe
de france on a mis trois cents de plus
quasiment là je parle bien de saint
denis du stade je parle pas du reste de
paris mille cent soixante dix pour leur
public il ya eu zéro agression de
policiers ou de gendarmes il y en a eu
dix pendant la championne si il ya eu
zéro c'est-à-dire agressé pour la coupe
de france il y en a eu dix dont un
gravement lors de ce match de
championnat et notamment ce qui faisait
le pré filtrage celui du rer d avant que
nous levions le sujet il ya eu trois
plaintes déposées pour le stade de
france il y en a eu 35 on y reviendra
pour le stage de championne zig et il ya
eu 28 interpellations lors de la finale
de coupe de france et à saint denis il
ya une trentaine d'interpellations par
ailleurs à paris notamment pour des
ivresses sur la voie publique 80 une
interpellation au stade de france dont
29 dans le stade de france qui prévoyait
les intrusions pour répondre à votre
question la moitié des personnes qui ont
été interpellées de son qui ont sauté
les grilles étaient des citoyens
britanniques
et sur les excuses et montréal nord dont
elle détaille et sur les 52 en dehors du
stade qui ont été interpellés c'est
effectivement les 13 qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure sur le parking vers ip et puis
les autres qui ont se sont livrés à des
rapides ou à des agressions en effet
donc c'est un montant important
d'interpellations par la sécurité
publique j'ai noté pour répondre
notamment votre question que sur les 80
une
interpellation que nous avons commises
25 ont été commis par des étrangers hors
de l'union européenne pour répondre
directement à la question je regrette
d'ailleurs qu'on est à détailler les
nationalités des personnes interpellées
mais je suis bien obligé de répondre à
quelques faits news qui circulent
malheureusement sur le paris et la seine
saint denis tous confondus y compris les
fans zone et 805 interpellations qui ont
conduit à 73 garde à vue je veux
rappeler ici que les musées intérieure
ne décident pas des poursuites
judiciaires des personnes que nous
interpellons j'entends qu'il ya des
questions sur la suite judiciaire je
suis parfois celui qui peut déplorer un
certain nombre de non poursuite
judiciaire mais je suis bien dans mon
rôle en vous parlant que des
interpellations de la police nationale
gendarmerie
alors qu'est ce que nous aurions d'abord
qu'est ce que nous pouvons faire des
immédiatement pour essayer de comprendre
encore mieux ce qui s'est passé
notamment vis-à-vis des personnes qui
ont été floués parce qu'il y en a eu
d'aidé floués et notamment des personnes
qui ont pu parce qu'ils sont citoyens
britanniques madrilène pas déposé
plainte et je ne veux pas sous-estimer
le fait que venant d'angleterre ou
venant d'espagne on n'a pas forcément le
même réflexe quand on vient de nantes au
canton vient de nice pour un match de
football donc je vais proposer qu'à
partir de lundi les citoyens espagnols
et des citoyens britanniques puissent
déposer plainte dans leur pays et je
vais dépêché des policiers français à
madrid et en angleterre je l'espère à
liverpool mais signe si ce n'est à
londres évidemment une plateforme
informatique en langue espagnole et
anglaise et puis des lettres plainte
déjà rédigé dans les langues de ces deux
pays avec des policiers français pour
qu'on puisse bien voir quelles sont les
suites judiciaires répondre évidemment à
chacune des plaintes qui serait déposée
avec les preuves notamment les preuves
vidéos qu'ils auraient pu faire et bien
évidemment faire des poursuites
systématiques de ces personnes et que
nous ayons et on vous communiquera
monsieur président de la commission des
lois les résultats parce qu'elle s'en
doute une partie des plaintes qui n'ont
pas été déposée parce que ses citoyens
repartent le soir même le lendemain dans
leur pays je veux aussi dire que le
parquet de bobigny s'est saisie pour les
faits commis de faux billets
de manière massive industriel je
maintiens le mot d'ailleurs j'ai
constaté que hier faisait elle même une
enquête sur ce sujet je veux dire qu'il
est tout à fait loisirs évidemment pour
d'autres pays de pouvoir faire les
enquêtes s'ils le souhaitent sur ces
faits je n'ai pas vu à ma connaissance
d'ouverture de ce point mais je pense
que nous serions tout à fait au rendez
vous et c'est la justice de le dire de
cette coopération et puis troisièmement
je pense que c'est très important on
doit tirer des conclusions pour la suite
mais la ministre des sports il reviendra
j'aurais simplement terminer sur les
questions d'ordre public
qu'avons nous mal fait nous avons sans
doute sous-estimé le nombre de policiers
ou en tout cas l'action de la police de
sécurité publique
à partir du moment ce qui était
difficilement prévisible mais être
ministre être responsable c'est sans
doute encore plus prévoir que l'ordre
public dégénérait et qu'on aurait levé
les barrages d'ordre public ce qui
faisait qu'une partie de l'espace entre
le rer d et le stade de france ont été
livrés avec peu de policiers à saintes
nombre de personnes qui profitant
évidemment de la confusion se sont
livrés à des violences et donc je crois
qu'il faut tirer conclusion de cela
prévoir beaucoup plus de policiers de
sécurité publique parce que chacun voit
qu'un policier d'ordre public casqués
avec son équipement dont le travail est
de faire de l'ombre au public n'est pas
là pour intervenir en délinquance à
quelques centaines de mètres y en a qui
l'ont fait je fais sans merci mais ce
n'est pas leur travail et c'est non pas
non plus la réglementation qui est
utilisée dès vendredi pour le stade pour
france danemark même si c'est ce match
un ange est plus réduit et dois je le
dire d'ailleurs que l'athée quasi
intégralité des billets sont
électroniques à quelques centaines prêt
mais la ministre y reviendra nous en
tirerons toutes les conséquences et
évidemment pour les matches et pour un
certain nombre de compétitions plus tard
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut faire un
effort extrêmement important pour la
ville de saint denis et pour la
préfecture de police de caméras de
vidéoprotection sur l'ensemble de la
ligne r-vrd stade de france puisque
c'est surtout le rer b la n 13 qui sont
vidéosurveillées dont acte j'y mettrai
les moyens dès le mois prochain pour
équiper l'ensemble cet axe
et troisièmement ça veut effectivement
aussi dire que nous devons anticiper ce
qui manifestement s'est passé ici au
stade de france en cas d'afflux très
important et non prévus on peut imaginer
attentat on peut imaginer une panne on
peut imaginer rassemblement un incendie
bref ce rassemblement sont tout à fait
possibles sans doute pas hauteur de 30
me met tout à fait possible un
dispositif d'urgence particulier pour
lutter contre l'insécurité le public le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment l'ordre
public moi je veux dire ici que les
décisions qui ont été prises ont permis
de sauver des vies il y a eu des gestes
inappropriés disproportionnée d'un
certain nombre de la part de policiers
ou de gendarmes mobiles qui ont été
documentés je veux dire qu'il ya deux
saisines igpn en tout cas de signalement
j'ai évidemment donné instruction et
j'ai peine de les étudier je veux dire
que lorsque les madrilènes et les
anglais pourront déposer plainte
des saisies gpn on leur expliquera bien
évidemment et j'ai vu personnellement de
fait ou manifestement l'ordre public et
l'utilisation du gaz lacrymogène était
contraire aux règles d'emploi et j'ai
demandé des sanctions aux préfets de
police pour ces deux responsables des
forces de l'ordre je veux cependant dire
il remettre dans le contexte que lorsque
des milliers et dans un certain car plus
d'une dizaine de milliers de personnes
se pressent
et malgré le fait que dans cette foule
il ya parfaitement des gens honnêtes et
des gens qui venaient au stade c'est
juste dire mon père en bonne mère de
famille pour faire reculer une foule qui
va connaître un d'écrasement les
policiers et les gendarmes sans doute
dans l'urgence et sous leurs données à
la hiérarchie pour utiliser des moyens
de dispersion est ce que ces moyens de
dispersion sont adéquats pour un
événement comme celui-ci manifestement
l'expérience mérite d'être très
largement revu et j'ai donc demandé dès
maintenant je sais de préfet quatre
cadeaux ils travaillent par ailleurs de
voir dans le cadre des événements
sportifs dans un événement exceptionnel
comme celui ci qui n'a jamais eu lieu
dans cette proportion en france on
puisse voir évidemment des règles
d'emploi différent je veux dire qu'elle
crs ou gendarmes mobiles ne l'est pas
d'autre moyen de faire disperser la
foule mais sans doute de la poste de la
faute de l'administration qui n'aiment
pas les moyens techniques de le faire
sinon c'était défilement des grenades
anti
rassemblement où dell bd ce qui
évidemment n'était pas du tout
proportionnée donc le gaz lacrymogène a
permis de sauver un certain nombre de
personnes de l'écrasement il a aussi
pesé côté des grands dégâts notamment
sur des enfants j'ai comme vu comme vous
voulez les images voudrais m'en excuser
très sincèrement de cette utilisation
disproportionnée et des sanctions seront
prises je voulais communiquerait si vous
souhaitez monsieur le président de la
commission des lois voilà ce que je vais
vous dire en quelques mois j'étais un
peu long mais il me semblait nécessaire
je tiens à votre disposition l'ensemble
des documents et je suis prêt évidemment
à répondre à toutes vos questions je
veux dire que la note des lainages que
vous aurez dans votre dossier ne prévoit
pas des milliers de faux billets
le mieux c'est puisque tous les
documents sont son public mais jamais
retranscrit intégralement et prévoit
deux fautes possible cette note de la
dette et lâche la première c'est que des
personnes tenteront de pénétrer par ruse
dans l'enceinte sportive en utilisant
par exemple des dîners forme de stewart
du personnel de l'uefa du personnel
médical des agents nettoyage se fait
demain prévu par la démarche n'est pas
arrivé fort heureusement on s'était
préparé à cela et deuxièmement de plus
et comme cela peut être constaté lors
des précédentes finales jouées par le
club de liverpool je rappelle ici que
n'a vu aucun problème avec les
supporters madrilènes et aucun problème
avec les autres supporters plusieurs
centaines de supporters anglais c'est
pas plusieurs milliers tenteront de
pénétrer dans le stade en forçant les
tourniquets et différentes portes
d'accès et donc nous avons prévu un pour
cela la fan zone et deux pour cela la
surnomme sur nombre de policiers comme
je voulais évoquer d'ordre public mais
effectivement qui n'étaient pas prévus
pour des dizaines de milliers je veux
aussi dire qu'il ya eu dysfonctionnement
puisque je dois la vérité évidemment à
la non pas la commission met à votre
audition que cette année n'a pas été
transmis à la préfecture de police
contrairement aux autres matches je m'en
suis inquiété personnellement je
multiplie les réunions pour savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est
effectivement un dysfonctionnement du
ministère je vais en tirer les
conclusions je prends évidemment cette
faute pour noël n'aurait pas changé à
mon avis grand chose puisque par
définition les craintes évoquées n'ont
pas été soumis puisqu'il n'y avait pas
des milliers des personnes prévues mais
il est évident que le préfet de police
qui est garant de l'ordre public à paris
au petit couronne aurait dû connaître
cette note
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
mise au point g indique d'ores et déjà
nos collègues que vingt et une personnes
intéressées nateur sénatrice se sont
fait connaître pour poser une question
donc ils le feront après que madame lamy
se soit exprimé je vous en prie madame
merci monsieur le président sur le
président de la commission des lois soit
noël buffet monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation laurent lafon mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs
j'ai évidemment honoré d'être devant
vous aujourd'hui pour cette audition
pour la première fois devant le
parlement ma qualité de ministre des
sports et des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques mais j'aurais bien entendu
aimé que cela puisse se produire dans
des circonstances plus positive
ma démarche
notre démarche avec le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est évidemment une
démarche de transparence la plus
complète possible devant vous et je
répondrai donc le plus précisément aux
questions que vous jugerez utile de me
poser à la suite de cet exposé
je voudrais peut-être dans ce propos
liminaire commencer par ray exprimer nos
regrets pour les personnes dont la
soirée a été gâchée samedi soir et pour
ses 2700 supporteurs de liverpool qui
alors qu'ils avaient validement acheter
leurs tickets ont été privés de ce beau
match
je voulais dit je m'inscris devant vous
dans une démarche avec le ministre de
l'intérieur de totale transparence
mais aussi de responsabilité
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès lundi
matin à 11 heures j'ai vraiment souhaité
réunir l'ensemble des parties prenantes
pour essayer de travailler à l'analyse
des incidents établir les
responsabilités de chacun et puis tirer
les enseignements qui s'imposent
l'uefa en tant qu'organisateur de cette
compétition
la fédération française de football qui
avait certains pans de responsabilité en
délégation de l'uefa dont je rappelle
qu'il maîtrisait l'organisation de cet
événement les gestionnaires de
l'enceinte le consortium stade de france
et puis du côté de l'état la préfecture
de police la préfecture de
seine-saint-denis la dnlh dont nous
avons parlé et puis la mairie de saint
denis en tant que représentant de la
collectivité haute du match
je voudrais vous dire
finalement peut-être les trois
principaux éléments que je retiens de
cette réunion de retour d'expérience d'
analyse
le premier point c'est d'abord la
convergence de vues et d'interprétation
sur ce qui s'est passé
certes nous avions tous des points
d'observation différents
complémentaires mais on s'est vraiment
assuré pendant ces deux heures de
travail intense que rien était
incohérent j'y reviendrai
le deuxième élément que je retiens c'est
qu'il y a comme souvent dans pareil à
faire une forme de conjonction de
circonstances de fait j'ai envie de
reprendre les mots du stade de france
quelque chose qui a entraîné un
processus dynamique est exponentielle
chaque pas franchi amplifiant les
difficultés rencontrées de manière
croissante
puis le troisième élément que je retiens
c'est quand même cette cause racines de
cette proportion extrêmement élevé de
faux billets
proportion peut-être inédite et
difficilement anticipable je voudrais à
cet égard et avant d'y revenir un petit
peu plus longuement relance youn et deux
points qui dans l'exposé du ministre de
l'intérieur me semble très important
d'abord dans cette note que moi non plus
je n'avais pas eu en amont que le
ministre de l'intérieur n'a partagé de
la dnlh il est bien dit qu environ 50000
super tôt supporteurs anglais seraient
présents dans la capitale sans être
détenteurs de billets et ensuite il est
précisé finalement trois formes de
difficultés à adresser la première il
est écrit certains d'entre eux seront en
position de faux billets est en train de
les utiliser pour accéder au stade
d'autres tenteront de pénétrer par ruse
dans l'enceinte sportive en utilisant
par exemple des uniformes de stuart
deux personnels de l'uefa de personnels
médicaux ou d'agents de nettoyage
notons que ce deuxième volet nous
n'avons pas constaté et puis en
troisième la dnlh s'identifier le risque
que plusieurs centaines de supporters
anglais tentent de pénétrer dans le
stade en forçant les tourniquets et les
différentes portes d'accès voyez bien
que dans ces termes
la proportion très forte de faux billets
n'étaient pas qualifiés parmi ces 50
milles nous n'étions pas alerté sur le
fait que le volume de ces faux billets
pourraient être aussi élevé un autre
élément que je voudrais mentionner c'est
le fait que le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a rappelé organisé en trois mois mais
aussi ne connaître que le 4 mai
l'identité des finalistes
dont le club de liverpool avec la
spécificité très forte de ses supporters
de leurs techniques et c'est donc le
temps d'adaptation à leur technique à
leur façon de faire peut-être aux
risques spécifiques qu'il présente ses
supporters ce temps nous a été
malheureusement très content et alors le
ministre de l'intérieur a été
formidablement exhaustif dans son dans
son exposé je ne vais donc pas du tout
revenir sur tous ces éléments il y en a
juste un sur lequel vous me permettrez
de revenir parce que il est pour moi
absolument capital dans tout ce que
j'entends ces dernières heures ces
derniers jours sur cette affaire j'ai
deux sentiments qui a la perception
d'une incohérence entre ces 30 à 40000
supporters sans billet ou avec de faux
billets et les 2800 faux billets scanner
aux ultimes portes de contrôle rapporté
par l'uefa alors
on a vraiment essayé de décortiquer au
mieux de l'information qui est à date en
notre possession de décortiquer cette
arithmétique de comprendre alors les
deux enquêtes celle auprès du parquet de
bobigny celle approfondie de l'uefa sur
la billetterie nous donnerons évidemment
d un petit peu plus précis mais je
voudrais partager ce qui pour moi n'est
pas une incohérence mais au contraire
une cohérence
d'abord et c'est le premier point
j'aurais sept points dans ce dans ce
passage le premier point le ministre de
l'intérieur l'a rappelé nos 35 me no 30
à 40000 plus exactement nous avons bien
dit que c'était soit des personnes sans
billets soient des personnes avec de
faux billets la proportion de l'un et de
l'autre n'étant pas clair étant
difficile à établir peut-être que les
enquêtes nous donneront un petit peu de
peu plus de visibilité sur ça mais elles
seront probablement difficile à établir
jusqu'au bout
ce qu'on sait c'est que ces supporters
sans billet cette première des deux
masses ils ont été tenus largement à
l'écart de la première zone de filtrage
et le ministre de l'intérieur l'a
rappelé les données de trafic dans les
transports en commun montre bien qu'il
ya eu un volume retour très très fort
avant même la fin du match de ses
supporters
donc ayant en tête que ce premier
ensemble de 100 billets étaient
vraisemblablement important avec ce flux
est ce premier ce premier élément de
deux filtres
le deuxième point c'est que c' est la
première zone de filtrage elle a rempli
son objectif de repousser un certain
nombre de détenteurs cette fois de faux
billets grâce au stylo chimiques qui ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure et là
l'ensemble des témoignages que nous
avons reçues sont concordants des agents
de sécurité et qui remonte une
proportion entre 55 et 70 % de faux
billets à sept premières zones de
filtrage là je vais vous rapporter une
anecdote qui m'a été comptés c'est qu'au
début
l'uefa ne croyait pas à ces statistiques
alerté par les stadiers qui étaient eux
mêmes surpris de cette proportion de
faux billets ils se sont demandé si ce
n'était pas les stylos chimiques qui est
défectueux et ils sont venus en
rapporter aux stadiers
le troisième élément qu'il faut bien
avoir en tête c'est que
c'est
une zone de premier filtrage uniquement
aux portes x y et z qui a été relâché
ce qui signifie que aux autres portes
cela a continué d'agir comme un barrage
comme un filtrage est d'ailleurs des
données qui ont été partagées par la
fédération française de football montre
qu'il y a même 33 % de ces faux billets
détectés qui relève d'autres portes que
x y et z
ceci nous montre bien que cette première
zone de filtrage elle a continué à
fonctionner tout au long de la période
de contrôle sur une partie significative
et rappelons nous la main courante
l'établi la zone de filtrage x y et z
elle n'a été relâché que de 19 heures 39
à 19h54 avant ensuite d'être rétabli
jusqu'à ce que vers 21h les stadiers qui
progressivement leur poste
le quatrième point c'est que quand on
passe sept premières zones de filtrage
et le fait que du coup les forces de
sécurité étaient positionnés côté x y et
z sur le parvis et bien elles ont pu à
leur tour écarté un certain nombre
d'individus qui d'évidence ne détenait
pas de titre valide pour accéder dans
l'enceinte du stade
le cinquième point c'est que lorsque
vous arrivez devant les tripodes les
agents de sécurité sont à nouveau un
barriérage où ils vérifient deux
nouveaux les billets de manière vie ul
ce qui leur permet d'écarter les fraudes
les plus évidentes et il vérifie
l'exactitude de la porte d'entrée
c'est donc au total ces cinq étapes
quand on arrive à l'entonnoir de ces
fameux tripode où les
2800 environ bibi est scanné irréguliers
ont été repérés qui est le sixième point
et puis nous avons un 7e et dernier
point puisque le stade de france établi
que malgré six étapes progressives il y
avait quelques centaines de spectateurs
sans billet ou sans billet valide qui
avaient réussi à pénétrer dans
l'enceinte du stade
tout ceci pour vous montrer que cette
dispersion des flux ces étapes
successives de l'entonnoir
établissent en réalité une cohérence
forte entre les 30 à 40000 que nous
évoquons au début et ce chiffre donné au
tripode par les données de contrôle
d'orange à l'uefa
me semblait vraiment utile de revenir là
dessus parce que je crois que c'est un
élément qui fait perdre la confiance
dans l'analyse que nous vous restituant
des faits alors même je le rappelle
qu'il ya cette très grande convergence
des analyses de vue et d'interprétation
entre l'ensemble des parties prenantes
alors je lui ai dit tout à l'heure moi
je m'inscris dans une démarche de
responsabilité tourner vers vers
l'avenir je voudrais donc revenir sur
les quatre décisions majeures que nous
avons décidé de prendre à l'issue de
cette réunion que j'ai animé hier matin
la première c'est que nous nous sommes
dit que la première chose que nous
devions faire était de réclamer une
indemnisation une compensation pour les
2700 supporters de liverpool qui n'ont
pas pu alors même qu'ils avaient un
billet valide assister à ce match et
nous avons demandé à l'uefa de pouvoir
les compenser rapidement de manière
individualisée
le deuxième élément c'est que nous avons
demandé à l'uefa et on se satisfait que
dès lundi soir elle est annoncé qu'elle
le ferait une enquête très approfondie
sur l'ensemble des failles constatées et
notamment sur ce point très sensible de
la billetterie ou notre enjeu est de
comprendre comment cette fraude a pu
être possible dans de tels volumes avec
quelle mécanique et quelles complicités
le troisième élément c'est j'ai demandé
au préfet cadot qui est le délégué
interministériel à la gestion des
événements sportifs de rassembler de la
manière la plus exhaustive possible
l'ensemble des analyses partagées par
toutes les parties prenantes dans un
rapport qui sera public et qui vous sera
transmis messieurs les présidents
la quatrième décision c'est avec gérald
darmanin nous avons convenu de notre
volonté commune de renforcer ce pilotage
des grands événements en particulier
pour les rencontres à risque
les échanges des derniers jours
permettent déjà de comprendre que nous
allons devoir nous améliorer sur au
moins cinq dimensions
la première c'est la gestion des flux
d'abord au sortir des transports publics
des transports publics est peut-être à
fortiori dans des situations de grève un
peu compliqué à anticiper à calibrer
avec une capacité renouvelée
de gérer des plantes secours des
itinéraires de délestage d'avoir des
scénarios de repli bien coordonné entre
l'ensemble des acteurs susceptibles
d'être activé avec de l'agilité
je précise à cet égard que sur cette
gestion des flux
nous devrons améliorer des dispositifs
au stade de france de barriérage qui
devront être mieux adapté à la pression
des spectateurs nous devrons travailler
sur l'optimisation de la gestion de
cette zone de premier filtrage avec des
aménagements matériels les moyens
humains bien recalibré une juste
répartition des responsabilités entre
les agents de sécurité privés et les
forces de sécurité et la volonté de bien
optimisé le positionnement de chacun et
puis la gestion du dernier kilomètre
nous amènera probablement aussi à faire
des choix politiques et stratégiques
peut-être de piétonnisation de certaines
voies d'accès pour écarter les risques
qui ont été remarqués samedi soir de
croisement de flux antagonistes entre
dévié ton des piétons et des véhicules
créant une dangerosité particulière
le deuxième enjeu sur laquelle nous
devons nous améliorer c'est la
communication la signalétique avec une
information bien meilleure à donner
notamment aux voyageurs et tout
particulièrement aux supporteurs dans
les transports en commun tant parisiens
aux abords du stade le troisième enjeu
c'est celui de la sécurité en
s'interrogeant évidemment sur les
contres les conséquences concrètes pour
les forces de l'ordre du contrôle d'un
dispositif parfois très vaste avec de
vastes plans de circulation dans des
circonstances parfois à risque et avec
cet enjeu majeur de la qualité de la
coordination entre nos forces de
sécurité intérieure et les agents de
sécurité privés mais aussi j'insiste là
dessus avec une attention particulière
précisément sur cette filière des agents
de sécurité privés dont nous savons que
ce sont des métiers en tension qui exige
une bonne qualité de formation et qui
seront cruciaux pour la gestion de nos
prochains grands événements
le quatrième en jeu au regard des faits
de délinquance constatés nous savons que
nous devrons veiller à une meilleure
intégration à une meilleure anticipation
des dispositifs de lutte contre la
délinquance au sein des services d'ordre
pour assurer et garantir la sécurisation
générale de nos grands événements et
puis le cinquième et dernier en jeu
c'est celui de la billetterie avec la
nécessité d'abord d'une utilisation plus
systématique de la billetterie
électronique tout en l'accompagnant des
travaux nécessaires sur la blogo chain
qui permettront de fiabiliser l'ensemble
mais aussi une attention particulière
aux risques de cyber sécurité
le deuxième point sur ce registre de la
billetterie c'est d'améliorer nos
techniques de prévention de la fraude on
le voit c'est un phénomène qui n'est pas
spécifique à ce qu'a connu la france
samedi soir et en la matière peut être
qu'une coopération européenne
internationale dans le monde du football
et peut-être un petit peu au-delà sera
nécessaire en matière de renseignement
je vous partage ses pistes de travail
ses premiers enseignements sur lequel
préfet cadot dans son rapport reviendra
mais je voudrais peut-être
vous livrer encore deux ou trois
messages le premier d'entre eux c'est
qu'il faut jamais oublier que notre pays
y compris dans le passé récent à cette
longue tradition fructueuse de réception
des grands événements je voudrais leur
rappeler la ryder cup en 2018 avait
réuni 270 mille spectateurs de 90
nationalités différentes
championnats de hand masculin en 2010 7
540 mille personnes celui féminin le
championnat d'europe de hand tenus sur
notre sol sans difficulté la coupe du
monde féminine de 2010 9,1 me 1,2
million de spectateurs roland garros en
ce moment avec ses quarante mille
spectateurs quotidiens
au delà de ce savoir-faire encore
confirmé le ministre de l'intérieur l'a
dit avec la finale de la coupe de france
il ya une qualité de gouvernance et de
mobilisation que je veux souligner avec
la délégation interministérielle aux
grands événements sportifs
l'adie job pour les jeux olympiques le
rôle de l'instance de coordination
nationale pour la sécurité des jeux et
de la coupe du monde 2023 avec le préfet
zied khoury et l'ensemble de ces
personnes extraordinairement mobilisés
pour travailler sur toutes les activités
de sécurité et de sûreté qui concourront
à la bonne organisation de nos
événements en conclusion
mesdames messieurs
vous l'avez compris on ira au bout de
toutes les conclusions sur ces incidents
au bout de toutes les leçons qu'il nous
appartient aux responsabilités d'en
tirer je considère moi peut-être c'est
la sportive qui parlent que ces
événements dont on veut qu'ils ne se
reproduisent jamais nous pousseront à
progresser à nous remettre en question
là où c'est nécessaire et à réunir
toutes les conditions de façon
irréprochable pour faire de nos grands
événements des succès sportifs mais
aussi les fêtes populaires que les
français sont en droit d'attendre
mais pensez-vous aussi aux britanniques
je veux leur redire tous mes regrets
pour ceux d'entre eux privés de ce match
mais aussi les appeler à une certaine
compréhension des difficultés que nous
avons rencontrées puisque lorsqu'on
regarde en détail le rapport fait par la
baronne louise caser sur les événements
de la finale de l'euro en juillet 21
entre l'italie
et l'angleterre
les choses ont été très difficiles
également elle parle d'un échec
collectif à anticiper les risques de 17
brèche dans le dispositif de sécurité
d'une période de confusion allant d'une
heure trente avant le coup d'envoi
jusqu'aux tirs au but de concentration
de foule de chute de barrières elle
évoque des attaques contre les policiers
l'esthua qui ont été d'une violence sans
précédent selon les organisateurs
souvenons de de tout ça
alors j'ai bien entendu été pour ma part
sensible l appel du club de liverpool
moi je veux leur dire que tout ce que
nous regrettons dans ce trafic dont on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin absolument de
2,2 de comprendre dans cette
désorganisation peut-être qui a tranché
avec l'encadrement avec lequel le real
madrid a accompagné ses supporters tout
ça ne retire évidemment rien au fait que
ce club de liverpool est un grand club
avec un grand coach et de grands joueurs
enfin
soyez vraiment persuadé de notre
mobilisation la plus complète la plus
totale pour faire du match france
danemark 2 vendredi soir une bien
meilleure expérience pour nous tous je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
madame je voudrais indiquer que nous
avons 25 intervenants je vous propose
deux fonctions suivante par groupes de
dix
jeffrey dix premiers le prix dans la
fois on fera les dix suivants et puis
pour le 5 derniers on comptera pas en
deux c'est compliqué en revanche
vraiment je demande aux collègues de
respecter les deux minutes d'ici peu et
au ministre également d'être concis dans
les réponses c'est la meilleure solution
sinon nous n'y arriverons pas donc si on
fait ça peut durer tard moi j'ai pas de
difficultés pas de souci monsieur michel
savin ensuite monsieur jérôme durain
puis madame jacqueline eustache brinio
puis ensuite monsieur lozach
monsieur jean pierre sueur
on va y arriver madame monsieur claude
kern
et madame marie pierre de la gontrie
et il est parti
on va leur prendre la place de
jean-pierre sueur monsieur assouline
ensuite
je cherche mes numéros qui ne sont pas
dans l'ordre monsieur hugonnet et enfin
monsieur paco bien monsieur
ça va vous avez la parole
messieurs merci merci monsieur
présidente messieurs les présidents
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier les présidents la
faune et buffet pour l'organisation
rapide de cette audition suite aux
événements qui se sont déroulés samedi
dernier lors de la finale de la ligue
des champions au stade de france les
images que nous avons vues et qui ont
été vus par 400 millions de
téléspectateurs sont catastrophiques et
incompréhensible
je vais pas revenir sur les faits et
vais passer tout de suite aux questions
que gilles ce qui je l'espère trouveront
des réponses précises de votre part
monsieur et madame la ministre afin de
faire toute la lumière sur ces
événements tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre je voudrais avec évoquer avec
vous votre communication
dès le samedi soir depuis le pc de
sécurité du stade vous avez rapidement
tweeté que les incidents ayant entaché
cette finale était uniquement de la
faute des milliers de spectateurs
anglais sans billet ou avec de faux
billets vous avez par la suite affirmé
que 30 à 40000 spectateurs anglais sans
billet ou avec de faux billets étaient
massés devant le stade
ah c'est ce qu'à trente et quarante
mille supporters s'ajoutent logiquement
les 10000 supporters de liverpool muni
de vrais billets eux mais qui à 21h
n'étaient pas encore entrés dans le
stade si on bat si on se base ses
affirmations sur la signifie qu'entre
20h et 21h entre 40 et 50 mille
supporteurs anglais soit plus de la
moitié de la capacité totale du stade
étaient devant l'équipement sportif le
problème monsieur le ministre c'est que
cette foule immense personne ne l'a vu
ce chiffre de 30 à 40 mille spectateurs
c'est votre chiffre monsieur le ministre
pas une image pas un témoignage parmi
les policiers d'oeufs et de nombreux
journalistes français et étrangers ne
corrobore votre étrange récit la sncf
que vous avez cités par exemple a
publiquement déclaré dans la presse
qu'aucun flux particulier aux plus
importants que d'habitude n'a été
enregistré dans d'autres sens après le
début du match où sont donc passés tous
ces gens
aussi monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur comme vous le demande le
président de la république et par souci
de transparence ou de crédit et de
crédibilité de la parole gouvernementale
je pense qu'il est et sera facile pour
vous nous avez commencé ce soir à le
faire à apporter des réponses de bien
vouloir détailler avec précision les
sources officielles vous permettant de
formuler de telles affirmations et de
vous engager vous transmettre rapidement
l'intégralité des documents officiels
dans des registres différents de
multiples dysfonctionnements étaient
contents conduit à ce fiasco en
audiovision grève du rer b mal anticipé
problème de pilotage du filtrage et
rattray d'un contrôle des billets des
dysfonctionnements qui appelle des
réponses rapides et vous vous êtes
engagés tous les deux à les apporter de
plus à aucun moment dans votre
conférence de presse de lundi monsieur
le ministre vous n'avez évoqué les 300
400 jeunes qui ont tenté et pour
certains nombres réussi à pénétrer sans
contrôle dans le stade en débordant les
stadiers d'autre part ces bandes ont
ensuite agressé et détroussé à la chaîne
était lesté des spectateurs agressé avec
une violence inouïe parfaitement décrit
dans la presse internationale
here is it sur une quantité de vidéos
monsieur le ministre j'ai deux questions
simples les mais les méfaits de ces
bandes de jeunes ont-ils eu un effet sur
le chaos de cette soirée cette stratégie
de communication en deuxième question
cette stratégie de communication de
cibler quasi uniquement les supporters
anglais at elle pour objectif d'éviter
d'évoquer ces actes de délinquance enfin
dans la même lignée vous avez souligné à
plusieurs reprises et encore ce soir que
la france avait eu seulement trois mois
pour organiser cet événement majeur qui
d'ordinaire exige 12 mois de préparation
ces données est contrainte était connue
quand le président macron est intervenu
personnellement auprès de l'uefa pour
accueillir ce match à la place de saint
pétersbourg monsieur le ministre avez
vous été consulté par le président de la
république comme ministre de l'intérieur
pour l'organisation et la préparation de
cette finale en france
une question à madame la ministre
monsieur le président quatre minutes
moins chers collègues je vous la poserai
après le mieux c'est de commencer par la
question et faire une explication qui
éventuellement après si on a le temps
monsieur du rhin
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre merci pour
la quantité d'informations vous nous
avez transmises on a bien compris ce qui
s'est passé maintenant on va chercher à
comprendre pourquoi ça s'est passé il
sait conjuguer beaucoup de préparation
de d'improvisation et jusque là un
festival de défausse assez peu fair-play
d'ailleurs sur les supporters anglais
les clubs anglais les grévistes les
détenteurs de faux billets alors que
c'est nous finalement qui avons marqué
un but contre notre camp puisque
l'essentiel des défaillances sur l'aura
bien compris sont des défaillances de
coordination de filtrage de gestion des
flux de notes reçues pas lu ou pas
transmises ce qui me fait dire que
finalement en voulant organisée à la
hâte cette manifestation a sans doute eu
finalement les les yeux plus gros que le
ventre et m'amène à quatre questions
est-ce qu'il ya pas un problème de
conception dans notre maintien de
l'ordre public c'est pas un sujet
nouveau on a eu l'épisode des gilet
jaune on pensait qu'on avait tiré un
certain nombre de leçons de cet épisode
manifestement non
le préfet de police at il des péchés les
bonnes unités sur place compagnie
d'intervention et braves sont elles les
mieux placés pour un certain nombre de
tâches qui leur ont été assignées
questions sur la préparation pourquoi
cette fameuse note dont maintenant nous
explique qu'elle explique tout ce qui
allait arriver n'a jamais été élu est-ce
que la djs et la préfecture de police se
parlent troisième question elle tient la
coordination opérationnelle entre les
flux qui venait du r b rer d et ceux qui
venaient du rer b pourquoi n'y a pas eu
de réentrée orientation plus tôt et
pourquoi
s'agissant des délinquants qui se sont
attachés à dépouiller les supporters
n'ont pas eu des forces pour intervenir
dernière question
est ce que il est vrai que le dispositif
de sécurité d'accès au stade est
expérimental qui avait déjà été testé
pour la coupe de france mais qu'on est
sur une nouvelle organisation
j'en veux pour preuve un arrêté
préfectoral qui permettait de fermer les
commerces ce qui n'avait jamais été le
cas jusque là est-ce qu'on a testé à la
hâte sans préparation un nouveau
dispositif pour un événement aussi
important merci madame lesage brugnaut
merci monsieur le président j'ai c'est
d'être très courte pour laisser
suffisamment de temps à mes collègues
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre grâce
à ce que tout le monde appelle le fiasco
de samedi soir
le monde entier a pu découvrir
effectivement samedi que la seine saint
denis n'était pas la californie san
lameer contrairement à ce que disait le
président de la république récemment et
moi je ne me réjouis pas de ces images
qui à travers le monde aux données voilà
des images de la france extrêmement
détériorée je pense que personne ne s'en
réjouit alors le ca de france il a
ouvert fin 1998 et la france elle a
changé depuis la fin de 1998 et lorsque
le président la république a
effectivement proposé que la france
accueille cette finale dans des délais
courts certes mais on le savait est ce
qu'il a été pourquoi nappes at-il été
mis sous votre égide monsieur le
ministre un comité de pilotage
réunissant au sein de votre ministère
tous les acteurs de cette manifestation
et je dis bien tous cela peut-être
aurait évité aujourd'hui de constater
que sa part marché de dire que ça allait
mieux marcher demain par ailleurs je
vous ai beaucoup écouter monsieur
ministre lundi midi lundi soir
aujourd'hui et vos propos ont beaucoup
choqué pourquoi un tel déni de notre
part de ce qui s'est réellement passé
pourquoi ne pas mettre les bons mots
derrière ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ne
pas dénoncer la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé et pourquoi ne pas présenter des
excuses aux espagnols et aux anglais ça
n'a pas été fait et enfin je termine au
vu des images qui nous ont tous atterrés
samedi parce que ça nous rajoute
personnes je me pose une question
monsieur ministre avez vous renoncé à
restaurer l'ordre public partout dans
notre pays
merci madame monsieur nozaki ensuite
madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président bond et là
effectivement pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir et pour voir qui
était responsable de quoi il ya eu c'est
évident certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements de débordement d'un
prévoyant surtout quand on prend
connaissance a posteriori de la note de
la dnlh du 25 mai et encore on a très
peu évoqué la question de l'information
des personnes concernées une information
qui sans doute s'est avéré défaillante
d'où certains mouvements de panique
première question très simple et très
direct mais ce mini de l'intérieur avez
vous la certitude que le gouvernement
s'est donné tous les moyens et notamment
les moyens humains pour que la soirée de
samedi dernier au stade de france se
déroule comme une fête de manière
paisible tout en respectant bien
évidemment le cahier des charges imposé
par l'uefa en lien avec la fédération
française de football car qu'on le
veuille ou non d'image du pays se trouve
un peu ternie par cet événement
deuxièmement sur la bataille des
chiffres je n'ai pas y revenir mais bien
évidemment ce qui a mis le feu aux
poudres c'est votre estimation des
trente à quarante mille personnes sans
billet ou avec des billets frauduleuses
juste à la périphérie du stade de france
et c'est vrai bon vous en êtes expliqué
tout à l'heure mais quand on fait le
lien par exemple avec ce que dit le
parquet de bobigny c'est à dire je cite
aucune garde à vue pour des faits liés à
des intrusions ou de faux billets cette
mollesse je dois dire un petit peu
interrogatif un petit peu dubitatif vous
en conviendrez et troisièmement je
termine par le rapprochement avec des
jets zee des grands événements sportifs
internationaux
nyon de parler de coupe du monde de
rugby des jo-2000 24 à paris et pourquoi
pas les championnats du monde de ski
début 2023 je crois honnêtement qu'il
faut pas tomber dans les amalgames et
comparez ce qui est comparable
il est évident que la problématique de
la sécurité pour la finale de la ligue
des champions entre le real madrid et
puis liverpool ça n'a rien à voir avec
la sécurité des épreuves olympiques de
canoë kayak ou de tir à l'arc bon ceci
dit il faut quand même tirer les
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir d'où ma question monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous envisagez de
faire évoluer de réformes et se dire est
globalement la doctrine française en ce
qui concerne dans la stratégie
sécuritaire pour ce type d'événements
afin de sortir d'une image qui est très
souvent une image du tout répressif
merci madame marie pierre de la gontrie
et ensuite monsieur claude coeur
merci président
2-2 question de demande
vous avez évoqué la coordination enfin
en écoutant les chantiers qui était à
venir mais pourrait-on avoir des
informations concernant la coordination
qui a été mise en place en amont entre
les différents services on a vu qu
effectivement l'épisode de cette note
fantôme montre que sans doute il ya une
difficulté travail collectif mais dans
quelle mesure est ce que donc on se sont
coordonner les différents services les
différents intervenants y compris le
stade de france la ratp la fédération
française etc et peut-on en avoir les
comptes rendus de manière à ce qu'on
puisse avoir connaissance du fait que
cette situation était sérieusement
préparer et anticiper
la deuxième chose qui est donc une
question et une demande c'est que après
vous avoir écouté longuement nous ne
savons toujours pas où sont passés les
30000 personnes
qui sont censées avoir causé les la
situation que nous avons connue vous
avez regretté car vous êtes quelqu'un de
malicieux le fait de ne pas pouvoir
avoir de disposition des drones mais
vous aviez d'abord des caméras de
vidéosurveillance et vous aviez un
hélicoptère qui survolait la zone et
donc cela doit être possible d'avoir
connaissance de ces images et je pense
que vous avez tout intérêt parce
qu'effectivement c'est comme ça
on a l'impression les français ont
l'impression vouloir raconter ce qu'on
appelle des carabistouilles et donc
montrer ces images de prise par
l'hélicoptère et nous pourrons voir de
manière précise les flux de personnes
qui ont ou non circuler car vous l'avez
peu dit je rappelle que la fan zone
anglaise était plein et qu'il y avait
donc quarante mille anglais qui étaient
dans le 12e arrondissement entre la
place sur le cours de vincennes entre la
place de la nation et la porte de
vincennes donc il ne pouvait pas être à
la fois là et autour du stade de france
visioconférence
oui merci monsieur le président merci
aux deux présidents ont l'occasion de
cette audition
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
je vais donc aller à l'essentiel est sûr
qu l'avenir puisque beaucoup de
questions déjà été posée et ben moi ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que le suite aux
événements catastrophiques ne samedi
soir en tant que rapporteur avec david
assouline de la mission d'information
suivie l'organisation des jets hop et
2024 la question sécurité devient
préoccupante voire inquiétante va
falloir assurer la sécurité des sportifs
les organisateurs les officiels des
personnalités des journalistes et
supporters en très grand nombre et ceci
sur différents sites et plusieurs sites
à la fois sans parler de la cérémonie
d'ouverture évoquée par le président
laurent lafon la problématique est donc
autrement plus complexe à traiter et je
suppose que cette question a été évoquée
avec le coja et le job et le cio
également et j'espère qu'elle le sera à
nouveau ouvert vous nous en dire un peu
plus et surtout envisagez-vous une
nouvelle procédure à mettre en oeuvre
suite aux événements de samedi soir et
éventuellement qui sera associé à cette
réflexion
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur david assouline et ensuite
monsieur legault n'est merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre
la france est un grand pays d'accueil
des événements sportifs
faut qu'on le dise tous ici parce que
c'est aussi à nous de défendre cette
image et ce savoir-faire
en 2016 nous avons organisé les
championnats d'europe de foot ça se
rapproche puisqu'il s'agit du même sport
c'est beaucoup plus demandés sur une
beaucoup plus longues périodes en france
et en région parisienne
à ce moment là nous étions en vague
d'attentats terroristes
et à part les incidents qui ont eu lieu
à marseille
ça a était une organisation parfaite
avec à peu près les mêmes acteurs y
compris en terme d' organisateur lui est
sain et c'est donc c'est pas nos
fonctionnaires c'est pas tous ceux qui
se dédie à cet accueil personnel
hôtelier éboueurs qui passe derrière
pour nettoyer on en sait quelque chose à
paris
qui sont en cause ni le savoir-faire de
ceux qui sont en charge la france est un
grand pays
mais bien une question de pilotage bien
une question de
pilotage conjoncturelle d'un événement
qui a la même nature que les autres que
nous avons su organiser et là ça n'a pas
marché
alors j'en viens à la question qu'a
posée monsieur du rhin qui est la
question de la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre alors la gestion d'un événement
comme celui là c'est pas que du maintien
de l'ordre c'est une un accueil ce sont
des familles ce sont des gens qui
viennent pour faire la fête pour
supporter est ce que il n'ya pas dans la
façon dont a été appréhendé l'événement
quelque chose de l'ordre de
les supporters de liverpool
les anglais égale hooligans et donc la
gestion n'a pas été la gestion de
famille et de masses populaires qui
viennent pour faire la fête
mais dès que des dérapages ont eu lieu
ou dépression eu lieu
une réaction comme ont réagi face
justement à des délinquants ou des
hooligans et ça renvoie la gestion de
beaucoup d'événements y compris de
manifestations revendicatives par le
préfet de police ces dernières années
donc je pose la question très concrète
quel on est ce qu'on peut nous dire
puisque vous êtes dans la transparence
totale vous dites que vous allez fournir
tout à tout le monde est ce qu'on peut
avoir la nature débrief qui ont été
faites aux forces de l'ordre avant sur
les dangers et sur la façon de réagir
est-ce que nous avons la possibilité
d'avoir le type d'ordre qui ont été
données au moment où les tensions où
commençait à avoir lieu les heurts
notamment d'envoyer des gaz que vous
même vous avez constaté et vous avez
demandé des enquêtes mais vous pensez
bien que ça serait un peu fort de café
qu'à l'arrivée on nous dise que c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est mis à tirer tout
seul parce que je ne sais quoi alors
qu'il n'avait pas d'ordre du tout
d'aller dans le sens de cette façon de
disperser au lieu de contenir et de
considérer que c'était d'abord une
manifestation sportive festive et
populaire merci monsieur assouline
monsieur hugonnet et puis monsieur bako
merci monsieur le président vos sorts
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
même si nous vous auriez préféré un
autre baptême du feu je suis quand même
au nom de la commission heureux de vous
recevoir ce soir et voir que le sport
est enfin un ministère de plein exercice
après avoir été traitée comme la
dernière roue du carrosse dans d'autres
pays ces dernières années
le seul mini c'est pas à vous que
j'apprendrai que pour assurer la
sécurité et avant tout il faut tenir le
terrain
or samedi soir hormis le milieu magique
du real madrid
personne n'a tenu le terrain clairement
la responsabilité de la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation la
des opc et je crois engagés ou en tout
cas cela demande des éclaircissements ma
question est simple qui était
le patron de ce dispositif sans vous
faire injure bien évidemment en tant que
ministre mais le patron opérationnel
qui était le patron de cette opération
je rappelle quand même qu'en 2006 alors
certes ça fait un petit moment mais
s'est déroulée devant 79 1500 personnes
une finale de championnat stig à paris
opposant déjà des anglais d'arsenal qui
ont perdu également contre barcelone
déjà des espagnols donc on sait faire
j'entends par les doctrines de
nouveautés non nous avons dans notre
pays tout ce qu'il faut pour le faire
c'est un problème d'organisation
clairement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler l'organisation de la démo pc
ce soir là qui tenait le dispositif
quels sont les rapports avec
l'organisateur et les stadiers de l'uefa
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président en question
s'adresse surtout à monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur qui n'est pas ministre
des affaires étrangères et donc que ça
peut expliquer que ces propos étaient
peu diplomatiques vis-à-vis de nos amis
britanniques et donc il n'a pas
travaillé pour l'entente cordiale c'est
une boutade néanmoins j'ai bien écouté
on a tous écouté ce qui nous a dit il a
insisté sur le fait que trois mois pour
préparer ce type de
rencontre c'était difficile alors que
quand on l'a fait que ce soit en 98 en
2016 finale de coupe du monde finale de
ce championnat d'europe il n'y a eu
aucun problème at on eu les yeux plus
gros que le ventre fallait-il faire ce
test entre guillemets après il ya deux
ou trois points très précis vous avez
monsieur le ministre beaucoup insisté
sur le pré filtrage près de la moitié de
votre démonstration concerne près
filtrage parce que visiblement c'est là
qu'il ya eu de grosses lacunes dans
l'ancien monde le prêt filtrage c'était
plein de petits points de près filtrage
madame la ministre a indiqué qu'il
fallait peut-être mieux baliser
réorienter faire des itinéraires de
secours je crois que c'est le mot vous
avez utilisé c'est évident mais ça
existait auparavant on est tous allés au
stade de france on a tous eu plein de
points de près filtrage or comme l'a dit
monsieur du rhin visiblement il ya eu un
changement voilà du jour au lendemain on
a voulu tester quelque chose est-ce que
c'était bien adapté concernant le
dispositif policier une mise vous avez
commencé à faire un mea culpa vous avez
dit on a fait en gros on a il y avait
des gens pour du maintien de l'ordre
mais pas assez pour de la lutte contre
la criminalité vous avez donné des
chiffres 326 hommes
visiblement ce n'était pas suffisant
c'était d'autant moins suffisant qu' il
ya des chiffres qui pose problème alors
il ya les fameux 40 milles si on fait
l'addition de tout ce que vous nous avez
donné il y avait en france entre 90 et
100 mille anglais 3 90 et 100 mille
anglais on adule savoir la veille ou
l'avant veille alors deux choses soit il
y avait cent mille anglais si vos
chiffres sont justes et à ce moment là
on l'a su et on s'est pas adapté à ces
cent mille anglais à ses cinquante mille
cent billets dont parlait la dnlh soit
il n'y avait pas cent mille anglais et
là c'est pas qu'on s'est pas adapté
c'est qu'on n'était pas prêts
eh bien je vais donner la parole aux
ministres hall l'ordre qu'ils souhaitent
pour des réponses les plus courte
possible avant que le président la faune
de la parole aux autres collègues
monsieur dame là je vais essayer
monsieur le président d'être aussi court
mais sauf ce serait évidemment les
questions il semble cependant avoir
beaucoup répondu dans ma présentation
moi je le ferai bien volontiers
rapidement je veux faire deux petit
rectificatif d'abord c'est pas le stade
de france je les dis par abus de langage
et la fédération française de football
et l'uefa qui a réalisé près filtrage
donc je veux rendre à faire là stade de
france le fait que ce ne soit pas les
responsables mais bien la fédération je
les dis rapidement je m'en excuse auprès
d'eux et deuxièmement je veux dire
également que avant sa position puisque
ce matin j'ai moi-même demandé qui avait
eu cette note de la tnh m'a répondu
qu'il n'avait pas qu à 16h41 25 mai la
dnlh a bien envoyé sa note à la
préfecture de police tant que je fais
moi même puisque j'ai eu l'information
pendant cette commission on en apprend
le béa culpa toute façon ça ne change
pas grand chose pour le contenu cette
note mais non mais le contenu de 70
n'aurait rien changé c'est ce que
j'essaie de vous démontrer gelé
communiqué d'ailleurs à monsieur le
président de la commission et lorsque
l'ensemble des documents évidemment elle
est tout à fait à démontrer pour revenir
aux questions sur la communication
monsieur le sénateur je crois qu'on n'a
pas lu le même
suite puisque vous évoquez celui ci que
celui que j'ai publié qui est encore je
vais pas m'attarder neft et de support
que ce soit sur avec la blocs chaîne
mais je voudrais juste dire monsieur le
sénateur que j'ai dit des supporters des
milliers de supporters avec des
guillemets pas parler des dizaines de
milliers à ce moment là parce que je vis
dans le pc du stade de france des
milliers de supporteurs britanniques
sans billet ou avec les familles ont
forcé les entrées et parfois violente et
les stadiers c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé voilà donc ensuite il ya eu
des informations plus nombreux je veux
dire dire à madame de la gontrie qu'on
peut discuter à l'envi d'utilisation des
images j'ai dit moi même dans mon
introduction qui avait des images qui
prouvait le retour pendant la première
mi temps pendant la première mi temps et
ensuite pendant la seconde mi temps de
très nombreux supporters britanniques
qui repartaient notamment par leur r&d
la sncf d'ailleurs dans la note que j'ai
transmise à votre prise en détruisant
des finances l'evoke elle-même
simplement je ne peux pas vous les
montrer ces images moi je vous parle ces
images là madame la sénatrice c'est à
dire les images du rer puisque je ne
peux pas vous les montrer mais je
propose aux présentes buffet s'ils le
souhaitent à présent la faune de pouvoir
les voir deuxièmement vous c'est pas
vous madame de la gontrie qui avait
suivi attentivement la loi sur lequel
vous avez d'ailleurs combattu le
gouvernement probable de pichot utilisé
des images aéroportée que ce soit des
drones des robots ou des caméras
installées sur des hélicoptères à savoir
que vous avez empêché le gouvernement de
pouvoir les faire voler 1 renseignements
devant judiciaire il est un peu curieux
madame la sénatrice de reprocher
désormais les conséquences des causes
que vous avez évoqué les images
notamment de retour puisque la grande
critique c'est de dire où sont passés
des milliers de supporters ou deux
personnes qui étaient autour du stade de
france ils sont disparus je propose
monsieur le sénateur si vous ne croyez
pas aux milliers de personnes qui sont
repartis sncf elle-même évoque pendant
la mi-temps et retour je te présente et
je crois un tableau assez clair et qui
sera public vous pouvez regarder je vais
proposer au président de regarder
évidemment cesser ces sujets et ses
images auprès des caméras de vidéo
protection qui démontreront que dès la
mi temps avouez que c'est un peu
étonnante que des supporteurs des
habitants repartent du stade ayant été
au stade je les ai pas vus partir voilà
le deuxième sujet suite la délinquance
bon j'entends bien
la question alors évidemment est-ce que
je connais à vacances il me semble que
depuis deux ans je la condamne et je la
condamne fortement est ce qu'on aurait
pu lutter davantage contre la
délinquance évidemment pourquoi cette
délinquance a été de façon plus
importante que dans les autres matches
je pense avoir expliqué c'est parce que
le dispositif de sécurité d'ordre public
a été levée notamment pour pouvoir
sauver des vies qui consistait à
l'écrasement aux débordements des
personnes extrêmement nombreuses parce
qu en surnombre et parce qu'avec des
faux billets ou parce que son billet qui
se présentait la décision prise par la
préfecture de police à sauver des vies
la conséquence a en effet été le livret
le terrain comme vous dites monsieur le
sénateur à une délinquance que les
policiers appellent d'opportunité je
l'évoquais je les dis je n'ai pas à le
cacher il est difficile de la mesurer
complètement c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que dans une formule tout à fait
originale est tout à fait novatrice nous
proposons à chacune et à chacun de
pouvoir déposer plainte et compris la
part de citoyens qui n'est pas dans
notre pays qui ne sont pas autres pays
qui sont repartis donc effectivement il
ya eu cette difficulté mais je trouve
que à la fois de la part la sénatrice
êtes vous-même de qui évoqué avec
beaucoup d' insulte la seine saint denis
et qui depuis plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs jours évoque une
essentialisation la délinquance en
évoquant des nationalités en mettant en
pâture un certain nombre de liens très
nauséabond qui font malheureusement
l'écho d'une campagne présidentielle que
pourtant les extrémistes ont perdu je la
trouve pas cela est extrêmement déplacé
je vous le dis comme je le pense je vous
dis exactement comme je le pense si si
je pense qu'il ya une norme et il faut
assumer le fait qu'il ya une forme il ya
une forme manifeste quand vous dites
madame que depuis 98 la france n'est
plus la même et gaza sami a changé vous
faites le jeu je crois de partie assez
extrêmes et je veux dire ici
je veux dire je veux dire madame que je
suis personnellement mais j'aime en
droit et mon opinion j'ai le droit
d'être d'être assez choqué par ce point
et je n'ai pas et puisqu'on m'a forcé à
le faire pour lutter contre défectueuse
a donné des nationalités des personnes
que nous interpellons et je suis
d'ailleurs j'imagine qu'après une
question sera quel type de français
avant nous interpeller mais je n'ai pas
encore cette question à ce niveau mais
je m'y attendais bien évidemment je veux
dire cependant que sur les
interpellations qui ont lieu la justice
poursuit ces personnes et quand on me
dit il n'y a pas eu de citoyens
britanniques ou de cidre et pour
intrusion ou pour faux billets qui ont
été mis en garde à vue d'abord on a
présenté 14 citoyens britanniques pour
les intrusions à la justice c'est normal
de les relâcher si j'ose dire ce qu'ils
reprenaient leur train ou l'avion ou la
voiture le soir même je sais que c'est
pas moi qui les relâchent un vote au
courant que ces autorités judiciaires
qu'il le fait et deuxièmement quand vous
n'y a pas de gens qui ont été arrêtés
pour des phobies c'est pas vrai il ya
des gens qui ont été porteurs de faux
billets en grand nombre qui ont été
interpellées et d'ailleurs ça fait
l'écho d'un article de presse sans
aucune espèce de discrétion mais surtout
les policiers d'ordre public il
n'intéresse pas les gens quand ils ont
un faux billets quand on est policier
d'ordre public ou gendarmes mobiles et
qu'on a en face de soi une foule de
milliers de personnes qui force
notamment dans des prés filtrage qui
sont faits par des stadiers d'abord
c'est pas le policier qui constate le
faux billets c'est bien la personne qui
embauchait agents de sécurité privés
lust alliés donc il ne peut pas
interpeller quelqu'un qui a un faux
billets je veux dire skali la fédération
française de football madame la ministre
remportez témoins dans la réunion de riz
texte du lundi matin c'est qu'au début
il pensait même que des stylos chimiques
qu'ils avaient livré était faux puisque
la quasi intégralité des billets qui
étaient vérifiées seulement du côté
britannique je veux dire que toute cette
histoire ne fonctionne que dans les
trois portes du stade de france qui
comporte 75 mille personnes et qu'on
compare que je crois une quinzaine de
porte ils ont tous l'ont cru que c'était
faux que tous les stades y ont stoppé
l'entrée en faisant remonter à la
fédération française de football que les
stylos ne marchait pas et d'ailleurs la
personne qui était en charge de ça nous
a dit mais on leur a dit que c'est pas
vrai mais sur même garanti 2 ans ils
sont venus vérifier eux-mêmes et partout
ailleurs les stylos fonctionné puisque
c'était des vrais billets et donc oui
les policiers dans leur public n'ont pas
à ce moment-là interpeller des personnes
qui a des faux billets parce qu'il avait
autre chose à faire il avait à gérer une
foule avec des enfants des femmes
enceintes des personnes qui venaient
faire la fête comme dit monsieur
assouline est donc en effet la consigne
donnée à des policiers d'ordre public
c'est pas d'arrêter des gens qui avaient
des faux billets c'est de gérer une
foule je l'assumé bien volontiers et si
c'est ça la faute qu'a fait la police
nationale gendarmerie c'est une faute
que l'on peut dire renier mais en tout
cas contraire aux règles d'emploi
d'emploi je veux dire évidemment on me
répondra monsieur du rhin qu' il n'y a
pas eu d'expérimentation nouvelle
dans cet ordre public s'y est dans cette
organisation là je veux dire d'ailleurs
que la billetterie que le contrôle des
billets que la diffusion des billets que
l'entrée du stade n'est pas la
responsabilité vous le savez bien d'état
ministère de l'intérieur donc il ya
d'autres autorités que vous pourriez
tout à fait si vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment auditionné ce qui a été
changée je les dis c'est une décision
qui a été prise par l'organisateur comme
c'était le cas pour la coupe de france
de faire des prêts filtrage au début
mais qui avait montré son intérêt pour
la coupe de france pour éviter justement
et des personnes trop nombreuses qui
était pour ceux qui ont déjà été au
stade en tant que simple spectateur à
l'entrée des tickets donc on peut
comprendre ça dessine au stade de france
elle a connu cette décision une
difficulté du fait que évidemment seul r
vrd grosso modo apporter un maximum de
monde concentré pas de chance sur les
virages anglais sans appareil c'est un
des virages espagnol mais regardez on
aurait eu de façon disent très
différente ces problèmes
et troisièmement devant des faux billets
extrêmement nombreux parce que papier
personne la vie dans ses interventions
mais je réussis le répéter le fait
extrêmement troublant quand même que
l'intégralité de ses billets soit en
papier alors que toute la compétition
est un billet électronique et que la
plupart de nos compositions sont en
billets électroniques je ferme la
parenthèse effectivement il ya eu ce
nouveau prêt filtrage mais qui était
nouveau au sens depuis la coupe de
france il a très bien marché coupe de
france et là il a permis sans doute un
autre drame parce que c'est peut être
pré filtrage ces dizaines de milliers de
personnes avec des vrais avec des faux
ou sans tickets seraient venus de façon
extrêmement nombreuse directement vers
les portiques de sécurité et sans doute
que les intrusions ont été extrêmement
massive et sans doute que le match
n'aurait pas eu lieu puisque les rues
envahissement de terrain fait que
quiconque a été au stade et france va
que les grilles on les voit d'ailleurs
sur des vidéos ne sont pas très grandes
qui est très facile quand on est
extrêmement nombreux et qu'on a débordé
le service d'ordre de rentrée très
rapidement sur le terrain donc je crois
que ce prêt filtrage organisé par la
fédération était une bonne chose on
verra le retour d'expérience il a marché
par coupe de france et il a permis de se
rendre compte des difficultés que nous
avons eues mais c'était la deuxième fois
qu'il disait les arrêtés pris par le
préfet de police sont des arrêtés qu'il
fait de temps en temps et pas simplement
pour ce match et qui était nécessaire
pour nos amis britanniques qui parfois
comme d'autres supporters je ne veux
poser de questions à personne
diplomatique peuvent consommer de
l'alcool il est possible que des
supporters de football singulièrement
britannique c possible aussi boivent de
l'alcool avant d'aller dans un stade
c'est peut-être un problème dans le
public que nous avons parfois d'ailleurs
les notes le dise qu'est ce que nous
avons fait nous avons autorisé à partir
de 18 heures la consommation d'alcool
dans le stade et non pas aux abords du
stade pourquoi parce que sa force les
gens à rentrer dans le stade quant à 18
heures vous avez un public important
qu'ils peuvent boire et qui peuvent voir
peut-être parfois beaucoup et qui
restent à l'extérieur quand vous
interdisez à la consommation d'alcool
dans le stade vous laisser des points de
fixation à l'extérieur et je vous
aiderai à la question de monsieur
assouline qui prévoyait qu en effet
monsieur du club liverpool n'est pas un
club comme les autres et toutes les
notes de renseignement le dise madrid je
vous rappelle la finale de ligue des
champions en 2010 9 exactement les mêmes
problèmes peut-être que c'est ce que
nous aurions dû anticiper je le dis bien
volontiers que nous avons connue en
france pourtant les madrilènes savent
organiser le match de football à grand
enjeu
même difficulté de faux billets des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
également en dehors du stade qu'il
n'était pas dans le stade avec le club
de liverpool je rappelle à wembley dans
il ya quelques années exactement les
mêmes difficultés
malheureusement il est certain que le
club de liverpool avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour lui il ya plein de
supporters formidable et très honnête
fait effectivement venir pour les
services de renseignement des personnes
dans la note de la délainage de mémoire
centre 100 et 50 hooligans qui n'a pas
eu lieu lors de ce match ci mais on se
préparait en effet à des comportements
différents que les supporters madrilènes
je le dis bien volontiers on posera la
question de savoir si c'était une erreur
et vous avez raison de la pose et je
veux dire très rapidement également que
sur la question que pose et madame de la
gontrie des comptes-rendus moi j'ai
aucun problème à ce que vous puissiez
vous les fournir il ya eu exactement
cinq réunions présidées par le préfet de
police 16 mai le 19 mai le 23 mai le 25
mai le 27 mai je vous passe
les horaires mais vous voulez vous les
verrez et il ya eu quatre réunions
organisées par ledit job c'est à dire le
directeur
interniste délicate a remis ça en charge
des événements sportifs auxquels le
préfet de police où la préfecture de
police a participé le 4 le 27 avril le 5
et le 19 mai donc il ya eu de très
nombreuses réunions et moi je n'ai
absolument rien pour en tout cas ce qui
relève du préfet de police puisque j'en
suis ils sont responsables pour vous
communiquer évidemment à votre président
et les comptes rendus nous n'avons
effectivement rien rien à cacher pour le
job je laisserais évidemment madame la
ministre elle le dira je veux dire que
sur les fans zone des 10 requis le 40000
supporters britanniques je pense qu'il
faut tout ce qu'on aime langage parfois
je me dis qu'ils disent c'est pas
toujours que des anglais c'est des gens
qui supportent aussi liverpool nous
connaissons tous des gens qui sont allés
supporter liverpool moi j'en connais
personnellement y compris dans les fan
zone où dans le stade mais par abus de
langage voyez bien ce que je veux dire
et je veux dire aussi à monsieur bako
dans la zone y ait eu quarante mille
personnes un cours de vincennes
tout est documenté pour dire qu'il ya eu
douze mille supporters britanniques qui
ont quitté deux heures avant le coup
d'envoi du match à 21h donc autour de 18
19 heures et qui ont emprunté les
transports en commun et qui sont venus
en plus au stade de france donc de dire
que d'un côté alassane tall et deux
coupes de france avec les gens n'ont pas
communiqué je rappelle qu'elle faisait
de verve depuis le matin je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le préfet de police a eu
à gérer depuis trois jours la présence
de supporters madrilènes mois et
britanniques beaucoup sur notre sol sans
que bien sûr il ya eu la fête et qui a
eu de difficultés particulières
donc je pense qu'on peut pas monsieur le
sénateur m exactement de dire ce qui est
au cours de vincennes n'a jamais eu et
au stade de france là encore une fois
tout est documenté et je veux vous
redire encore une fois quel site de la
ratp la sncf de la fédération française
de football qui n'est pas sous
l'autorité du gouvernement les à
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
près et les bornages de la connectique
orange évoque la même chose que nous
alors je t'appellerai monsieur présent
je m'excuse être long sur finalement les
trois questions fonctionnel sur la
sécurité qui était responsable du
dispositif
j'arrive j'arriverai par vous si vous me
permettez aux sénateurs le préfet de
police qui était en salle de
commandement de la préfecture de police
je rappelle que pour nous le moment le
plus dramatique c'était le post match
avec un club anglais des supporters
chauffés à blanc si j'ose dire qu'ils
aient gagné ou qu'ils aient perdu est un
rendez vous entre la fan zone le stade
de france et les champs elysées donc le
préfet de police étaient en salle de
commandement et le directeur de cabinet
je n'ai moi même vu du préfet de police
étaient au stade de france et quand je
suis moi même remonter avec la ministre
des sports a
oppressé sécurité qui est au stade de
france il y avait dix représentants de
l'uefa des représentants de la
fédération les gendarmes mobiles les
policiers de la pp
les représentants évidemment delà des
opc sous commandement du directeur de
cabinet du préfet de police est elle
également préfet de seine-saint-denis
dont vous savez que depuis la forme de
bébé il n'a pas de compétence dans
l'ordre public donc voici les deux
personnes qui commandait ses services je
veux dire à monsieur bako que ne peut
pas compter les choses en disant qu'ils
avaient
80000 et 100000 anglais et qu'on les
aurait pas prévu on les a évidemment
prévu les points de filtrage de la paf
démontrent qu'ils sont passés évidemment
par plusieurs endroits et ils ont
notamment privilégier la voiture et les
passages en bateau je pourrais
évidemment le document t on les a
évidemment accompagné on ne s'attendait
à beaucoup d'anglais sur le sol national
on s'attendait à simplement à ce qu'ils
aillent dans les fan zone et que ceux
qui avaient des billets aille au stade
de france notre erreur a sans doute des
deux peut pas voir que des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui n'avaient pas
de billets ou des faux billets qu'on
n'était pas au courant des faux billets
sinon évidemment nous aurions fait je
crois des choses bien en amont en
enquête directement au stade de france
alors cependant il y aurait-il des idées
d'itinéraires de recours vous avez tout
à fait raison est d'ailleurs l'une des
petites erreurs qu'a commises sans doute
l'autorité qui commandait le barrage
c'est que on a accepté le détournement
alors la carte n'est plus là mais par le
contour du rer d qu'autour de
18h50 et on aurait sans doute dû le
faire avant devant l'accumulation de
personnes mais je crois que ce qu'il
faut bien voir et j'en excuse bien
volontiers les policiers et les
autorités de la fédération française de
football je crois que pendant plus d'une
demi-heure les autorités notamment les
stadiers n'ont pas compris ce qui se
passait et que l'une des erreurs c'est
que pendant plus d'une demi heure on n'a
pas compris pourquoi ces billets ne
fonctionnait pas pourquoi les stylos ne
fonctionnait pas ou ne faut il vraiment
cool keystone et pendant un moment ils
ont arrêté de contrôler mais c'est
préfet de police qui a décidé d'abord le
contournement puis ensuite de lever près
filtrage donc je j'entends ce que vous
dites et on peut tout à fait se dire de
manière opposée que c'est ce qui aurait
dû être fait plus tôt et c'est ce qu'il
faudra faire sans doute pour les
prochains matches il peut avoir sur les
regarder des grèves comme c'est le cas
vendredi des attentats en plein de
difficultés extra normal et on pourrait
imaginer que le plan b immédiat ce soit
le contournement vous avez parfaitement
raison mais je veux dire dans cette
situation exceptionnelle je comprends
que pendant une demi heure les
responsables de la fédération et la
police de la gendarmerie et du mal à le
comprendre ce qui s'est passé je me
rappelle encore une fois ni mort ni
blessé grave malgré évidemment l'image
déplorable que cela donne je veux ici le
rap et j'imagine que s'il y avait eu un
décès dans cet épisode les explications
n'aurait pas été bien évidemment les
mêmes et les responsabilités donc enfin
monsieur pardon monsieur président
monsieur la solide il faut réduire je
vous avez tout à fait raison je m'en
excuse
vous avez parfaitement raison dans votre
question c'est à dire que vous avez posé
la question indépendamment dans public
donc je crois avoir répondu qu'il
fallait revoir ce rayon sportif sera
certainement et bien sûr que c'est pas
un match de water-polo un max de hockey
sur glace je voulais leur dire que dans
les mêmes circonstances on a fait deux
grands matches de rugby internationaux à
marseille avec des supporters parfois un
peu dur oui s'est jamais rien passé donc
certes la france est tout à fait capable
d'organiser ces événements nous nous
tirons pas des balles dans le pied en
prévision de 2 juste polémique
électorale me semble-t-il c'est aussi me
semble-t-il fierté nationale que de
pouvoir le faire mais vous êtes tout à
fait raison quand l'euro 2016 les choses
sont parfaitement bien passé par le
gouvernement de la république et par ses
fonctionnaires pour avoir comme j'étais
directeur de cabinet dans 5000 et sports
en 2012 préparait une des candidatures d
euros je sais à quel point effectivement
les français sable organisé et tout en
revient monsieur cazeneuve qui a su bien
organiser l'euro 2016 auprès de sécurité
dans les attentats que vous évoquez la
question que vous évoquez principal c
est ce qu on n'a pas fait une erreur
d'appréciation en disant accueillant
liverpool
attention à tout le monde puisque nous
avons affaire à des gens je ne dirais
pas dangereux enfin en tout cas qu'ils
ont un certain passé est ce que c'est
une question difficile il est évident et
toutes les notes de renseignement le
dise que le kop de liverpool pose des
problèmes d'ordre public n'ont pas tous
ses supporters mais une partie petite
partie des supporters est effectivement
le dispositif de sécurité qui a été mis
en place et un dispositif d'ordre public
important et que c'est une erreur sans
doute que d'avoir
anticipé nous dit kahnisme qui et
finalement pas arrivé non mais je vous
ai bien sûr heureusement parce qu'une
foule plus oligan poser des problèmes
évidemment énorme mais chacun connaît et
comprend ce que je veux dire quand vous
parlez de vote de renseignements qu'on
consent serait pas inspirés de ne pas
dire tout et son contraire et parce
qu'on a libéré le dispositif devant leur
public qui était sans doute même un peu
trop important peut-être par rapport aux
clubs que nous recevions je rappelle
encore une fois comment toute la soirée
aucun pré requis madrilène dont quatre
avec d autres nous n'avions pas mis le
dispositif de sécurité publique qui
permettait de lutter contre une forme de
délinquance qui n'est pas structurelle à
la seine saint denis stade de france je
veux le dire pour éviter les fantasmes
mais qui a été l'
aider pour reprendre le mot du terrain
du fait qu'il y avait humilié et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes en
plus qui ne rentraient pas dans le stade
qui était étranger avec un seul rer qui
fonctionnaient quasiment quasiment pas
et qu'ils avaient de leur public qui a
qui est partie du terrain pour pouvoir
regarder les grilles donc sans doute
pour répondre à votre question monsieur
assouline nous avons une somme attendue
à liverpool a des problèmes les
problèmes ont pensé qu'ils viendraient
de l'hooliganisme des mouvements de
foule violent il n'est pas venu de là il
est venu des faux billets voilà
malheureusement je vais vous dire
quelque chose on anticipera mieux la
prochaine fois sans aucune espèce de
doute et c'est sans doute une
explication je le dis bien volontiers de
ce qui s'est passé samedi soir merci
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
mais je vous demande d'état c'est assez
courtes dans le propos parce que nous
avons encore un certain nombre de
questions et il faut que l'on avance mal
à nice peut-être simplement pour étayer
un la récurrence des échanges qui ont eu
lieu entre l'ensemble des parties
prenantes
la première réunion a eu lieu dès le 4
mars soit après quatre jours après la
désignation de la france comme pays hôte
de cet événement dont je rappelle que
l'organisation était placée sous la
responsabilité de l'uefa c'est au total
jusqu'au jour du match une quinzaine de
réunions qui ont eu lieu entre l'uefa la
fédération de foot le consortium du
stade de france la préfecture de police
djs les différentes parties prenantes au
sein du ministère de l'intérieur ces
comptes rendus ont été produits et le
ministre de l'intérieur l'a dit nous
n'avons aucune objection à ce qu'ils
puissent être partagés merci valable
jeudi la parole à au président la faune
pour les 10 prochaines questions
peut-être plus d'ailleurs en verrons
alors j merci merci président du fai
alors nous allons commencer par thomas
dessus et ensuite valérie boyer
merci à eux bien sûr ça
merci monsieur le président j'ai une
question pour monsieur me de l'intérieur
et une autre pour madame la ministre des
sports donc je vais prolonger la
question de mon collègue assouline
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez évoqué l' usage parfois abusive des
lacrymogènes on en a vu et 400 millions
de personnes dans le monde ont vu que
des lacrymogènes ont été utilisés sans
discernement avec parfois une certaine
nonchalance en direction des supporters
qui étaient en règle qui attendaient
pour pouvoir rentrer vous avez annoncé
des enquêtes concernant les agents qui
ont le malheur d'avoir été filmés dont
acte mais mes questions par plus
largement sur l'usagé global de ces gaz
alors ma première question ce serait ce
que des sommations des consignes ont été
transmises aux supporters avant leur
usage et par quels moyens et en quelle
langue j'essaie de comprendre si notre
police est actuellement capable
d'accueillir un public international
vous avez ok vous même un changement de
doctrine en matière d'utilisation de ces
gaz lors d'événements sportifs alors moi
je veux poser la question pourquoi se
restreindre à ces événements dont
changement de cette doctrine puisque
nous avons toujours observé depuis des
années des abus du même genre qu'on a pu
voir en direct samedi soir dans des
manifestations classiques n'est-il pas
enfin temps de changer de doctrine dans
les usages de ces gaz et de viser une
méthode de maths alors tourner plutôt
vers la désescalade
et puis ma question à madame la ministre
des sports lors de l'étude de la loi
sport nous avions échangé avec votre
prédécesseur sur la gestion plutôt la
non gestion des déplacements de
supporters en ligue 1 ces dernières
années notamment concernant la
multiplication des arrêtés préfectoraux
d'interdiction de déplacement est ce que
cette politique d'interdiction de
déplacement n'a pas abouti à une forme
de perte d' expertise
de nos forces de l'ordre en matière de
gestion des supporters allez vous
engager un réel travail avec les
instances les clubs les groupes de
supporters et les autorités pour ces
quarts sécurisés et maintenir garantir
ses déplacements de supporters je vous
remercie
valérie boyer
président monsieur ministre de
l'intérieur ma question s'adresse à vous
je me permets
ce n'est pas simplement om là où
aujourd'hui si cette affaire a pris une
telle ampleur histoire de faux billets
même si je ne mésestime pas leur impact
mais parce que les personnes ont été
agressé et détroussé la france désormais
septième puissance mondiale a montré ce
que tous qualifie désormais de fiasco
devant la triste évidence monsieur le
ministre après avoir ciblé les
supporters anglais vous avez ensuite
évoqué une campagne aux herbes on vous
avait même repris ce terme en
stigmatisant mes collègues qui vous
poser une question alors je vais vous
citer syndicats de police qui
s'exprimait de la façon suivante
donc citation que j'ai retrouvé dans la
presse je les cite nous n'avons jamais
vu autant de mineurs isolés il citait
leur origine regroupe les hyperactifs la
délinquance locale était aussi présente
mais ce n'était pas dominant du tout une
chose est sûre des pickpockets sont
venus en nombre pour voler du cash des
portefeuilles de téléphone parfois même
à des malvoyants ou à des personnes en
fauteuil roulant selon je continue de
les citer il y avait tellement de vol en
flagrant délit qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
interpeller tout le monde aussi
considérez vous que les syndicats de
police sont une campagne nauséabonde
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question visiblement le problème d'ordre
public était majeure et aurait dû être
cité en premier lieu
avant peut-être même les billets ou de
stigmatiser les anglais parce que ce ne
sont pas les faux billets qui agressent
et qui détrousse comment expliquez vous
monsieur le ministre la quantité de vols
et d'agressions puisque lisiblement la
police dit qu'ils étaient tellement
nombreux qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
interpeller tout le monde et enfin
monsieur le ministre le figaro relate
aujourd'hui des agressions sexuelles
lors de ces vols et de ses forfaits et
aux abords du stade de france
si ces agressions sexuelles ont eu lieu
qu'on existe et pourquoi le silence
si elles n'ont pas eu lieu pourquoi ne
pas justement dire qu'elles n'ont pas eu
lieu je vous remercie merci chers
collègues à la marque et ensuite
laurence garnier
merci monsieur le président
madame et monsieur le ministre nous
avait décrit temporellement les
événements de la soirée avec précision
et je ne vais pas revenir là dessus je
sais aussi le travail remarquable que
font les policiers gendarmes malgré
quelques dérapages les enquêtes ont été
diligentées
ce qui m'inquiète moi surtout si la
perception dégradée de la france quand
les images de violence de vols à la tire
sont vus dans le monde entier alors afin
que l'image de notre pays qui est très
attractif pour les touristes du monde
entier mais aussi pour les entreprises
qui souhaitent s'installer en france
soit restaurée il est absolument
impératif que les événements planétaires
organisé en france en 2023 la coupe du
monde de rugby en 2024 les jo soit
réussie
j'aimerais un petit peu comprendre
plusieurs intervenants madame la
ministre l'a dit consortium stade de
france l'uefa fédération française du
football préfecture de police ont chacun
un rôle bien précis dans des espaces
bien précis
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il y a eu un
problème avec l'autorité
coordonnatrice de tous ces entités et
donc de tous ces espaces puisque
apparemment il ya des supporters qui ont
été d'un espace à l'autre
laurence garnier
provisions
jeu elle n'est plus là peut-être que la
parole à un homme si vous mettre
d'accord
oui merci une surprise et de deux
petites remarques préalables d'abord sur
l'expérimentation des contrôles de près
filtrage qui aurait été fait bien avant
cette fois ci je suis pas sûr que ce
même si ce n'est pas sous votre autorité
directe que c'était bien le moment pour
expérimenter doute l une telle chose
deuxièmement sur les billets papier même
si là aussi c'est pas directement vous
est ce qu'ils étaient est-ce que ça pose
pas la question du mode
d'authentification des billets est ce
que vraiment il y aurait pas lieu de
voir une infection plus approfondie là
dessus pour éviter ce genre de daken
troisièmement sur l'évaluation du niveau
du risque
vous avez fait dit que la coupe de
france avait un risque supérieur
selon vos informations
franchement il faut même pas être
amateur de football pour comprendre que
la chambre conflit qui l'événement un
événement sportif majeur et d'au delà et
qui fait 400 milles 4 5 millions de
téléspectateurs et qui a une billetterie
qui demandait qui est bien au delà des
capacités du stade pour savoir que c'est
un événement keim qui est par nature
spéciale qui est qu'il doit mener une
réponse en terme de sécurité adaptées
enfin sur l'évaluation sur l'analogie
que j'ai fait pour le précédent avec la
chambre classique de 2019 entre
tottenham et liverpool je suis pas sûr
qu'elle vaille parce que effectivement
j'ai vu quelques faux billets mais ce
n'était pas de cette ampleur là et je
pense que l'analogie de ce point de vue
ne peut pas être fait mais plus
largement monsieur madame la ministre
moi je suis frappé par
on a parlé de déni mais l'euphémisation
que vous avez dans vos propos et dans
l'analyse que vous faites de la
situation on a eu un événement majeur
est certes ce soir est un petit
rétropédalage mais exprimé des regrets
moi je serai anglais supporters de foot
jeu j'aurais payé mes billets mon
hébergement et je peux pas rentrer au
stade et je me suis fait voler et
violenté et on exprime des regrets moi
j'ai exprimé mes excuses mes excuses au
président de club mes excuses au maire
dé liverpool et mes excuses au premier
chef
victime de ces personnes et je pense que
mettre le trouble sur les supporters
anglais de liverpool quand tu connais
l'histoire du club de liverpool comment
ils ont précisément pris des mesures
drastiques pour réduire et supprimer le
hooliganisme de laisser entendre qu'on
est encore là je pense que c'est mal
venu et ça rajoute à l'erreur
d'appréciation qui est qui a été fait à
ce niveau là moi je pense que on aura
beaucoup de mal à
corriger l'image dernier qui est qui a
été
consécutive à ces événements de funestes
et maintenant ça va poser effectivement
notre capacité à organiser de grands
évènements dans de bonnes conditions on
sait bien tout ce qui nous attend en
2023 et en 2024 et il est plus que temps
non pas nous tourner vers l'avenir
madame le ministre mais nous tourner
vers ce qui s'est passé pour bien
comprendre les causes et les corriger
rapidement
jacques grosperrin a suivi de l est
merci président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mais aussi en
contenant de l'epo de france a beau
bonhomme j'entre du des regrets à mea
culpa très léger et jamais des excuses
et pourquoi pas d' excuses car vous
refusez votre responsabilité dans cet
événement et lorsqu'on refuse alors on
comprend vous n'avez pas l'entière
responsabilité lorsque j'entends que
c'est lui et voilà la responsabilité ça
se passe quand même néanmoins sur le
territoire français et vous avez une
responsabilité si ce n'est vous qui
n'avez pas la responsabilité c'est le
plaisir la république qui a choisi bien
sûr de manière très rapide certainement
de faire cet événement à saint denis
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure 18 morts
en trois mois je pense qu'il aurait
fallu réfléchir et c'est sa
responsabilité qu'est mise en jeu
lorsque je vous entends monsieur mais le
ministre est dire à madame y jacqueline
aussi au style brio le faire lui faire
parler et lui dire comment me donner il
ya des propos qu'on doit pas à boire
thierry henry on ne peut pas lui
reprocher certaines choses lorsqu'il a
dit que le stade de france n'était pas
paris mais que c'était sa denis
conseiller une personne déguisée en faut
supporter on sait que le maire de
liverpool en train de faire une enquête
en ce jour et il propose un ensemble de
personnes de venir sur le terrain j'ai
ité à un jour trois questions la
première c'est l'intervention de police
est ce que ça a été adapté propose la
situation à ce que je pense que les gaz
était prévu pour dix hooligans et on
s'est rendu compte qu'ils n'avaient pas
de l'icann la deuxième question c'est
que pensez vous des réactions du monde
entier sur cette piètre image de notre
pays et enfin est il nécessaire de
réagir de façon aussi agressive à
l'encontre de nos voisins anglais parce
que vous des foyers depuis le début
uniquement sur une fausse billetterie je
crois qu on veut donner vous honorez
veillez à vous excuser parce que je
crois qu'il n'est jamais trop tard de
présenter ses excuses aux supporters
britanniques géomètre six présidents
aussi à vous demandant d'être le plus
rapide possible pour que chacun puisse
poser une question alexandra marche au
fond comme
maxime messieurs les présidents madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous interroger sur deux poids
qui à mes yeux revêtent une importance
particulière premièrement concernant la
consommation d'alcool aux abords du
stade et la vente à la sauvette
l'article l332 tiré 4 du code du sport
pro et vous le savez l'entrée des
supporters en état d'ivresse pourtant
nombreux sont ceux qui comme moi
pourrons vous décrire ses ventes
d'alcool sauvages dans des bacs de
fortune aux abords du stade et je ne
m'attarde pas sur les barbecues
clandestins dans des conditions
d'hygiène déplorables une arrivée au
stade qui renvoie une image comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer très négative et peu
rassurante finalement pour les visiteurs
monsieur le ministre comment
expliquez-vous qu'à la sortie de la
pandémie des ventes à la sauvette
subsistent et soit tolérée alors
qu'elles représentent un danger au
fondamental pour notre sécurité
notamment pour notre sécurité sanitaire
deuxièmement ce qui concerne la lutte
contre la menace terroriste
comment expliquez vous que j'ai moi même
pu accéder au stade sans fouilles
préalables un manquement qui ne peut
qu'inquiéter les cultures participant
aux grands événements sportifs et
culturels de notre pays enfin madame la
ministre vous allez ce matin elle citait
le tweet de notre président de la
commission des lois je vous cite donc
krak in dub fraîcheur c'est le titre
d'un récit de sportifs pour qui
d'ailleurs la seule limite est de
toujours là repoussé alors j'espère que
vous mesurez elle qu'il faut parfois
quand on est en responsabilité c'est à
la ministre que je m'adresse aidant à la
sportive avoir une parfaite conscience
de ses limites surtout si on veut les
élargir je vous remercie alain richard
monsieur le ministre
je ne pense pas que ce soit la première
fois qu'il y ait eu une défaillance de
la ligne b avant un match important
est donc
temps que francilien nous sommes
quelques-uns à éprouver que la ligne b
n'est pas d'une fiabilité totale
indépendamment des événements sociaux et
donc il ya quand même quelque chose de
surprenant vous fait qu' il y ait une
improvisation sur sur le siège du préfet
lui même semble-t-il revoilà par où on
va faire passer les gens qui sont qui
sortent en trop grand nombre par
une gestion de flux complètement
inadapté donc comme les jeux vont
comporter beaucoup d'événements en seine
saint denis que on va se retrouver avec
des sujets de surcharge en tout cas de
surpression sur les transports publics
du même ordre il me semble qu'il ya
quand même un retour d'expérience un peu
sérieux à faire là dessus je trouve un
peu surprenant que ce point n'est pas
été vu auparavant
deuxièmement le sujet du traitement des
activités pickpockets
c'est forcément de la sécurité publique
et vous avez indiqué que des effectifs
plus importants avaient été prévus mais
est-ce que sur l'expérience des
événements sportifs antérieures où ces
phénomènes lui également vous considérez
que la méthode la doctrine d'emploi de
la sécurité publique pour intercepter
les cas de
deux pick pocket et donc pour dissuader
que ça devienne endémique est ce que
vous considérez que notre méthode à
l'heure actuelle sur ce sujet est
satisfaisante et est-ce qu'il faut pas
là encore
anticipé des événements où ça va se
reproduire et enfin un message aux deux
présidents je pense que nous ne
perdrions pas de temps à russell nous ne
perdons pas notre temps à recevoir dans
quelques semaines le préfet michel cadot
quand il aura fait ce rapport
mais si j'ai un collègue éric kerrouche
et enfin gering bas qui
solutionne monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ma question s'adresse pas à
mes questions s'adresseront
essentiellement à vous d'après les
informations que j'ai pu recueillir le
préfet de police disposés pour
l'événement dont nous avons parlé toute
cette soirée de 36 unités de forces
mobiles qui représentent à peu près à ma
connaissance 33 33 % des effectifs de
ses forces nationales et il n'a choisi
d'en déployer uniquement 10 de ses
unités au stade de france
c'est difficile d'expliquer ce choix au
vu de la note dont on a parlé vous avez
dit mais c'est surprenant qu'elle
n'avait pas été transmise d'accord il
n'en demeure pas moins que qui a été mis
au courant de ce choix stratégique du
préfet de police est ce qu'il a été
validé par vous par votre cabinet dans
des réunions en amont ou est ce que il
ne s'agissait que d'une décision
personnelle dernière question
comment peut-on expliquer le choix de
déployer la brigade de répression de
l'action violente sur le stade alors que
cette brigade n'est pas adapté à ce
genre d'événement au détriment notamment
des crs on comprend votre explication
avec les faux billets qui peuvent
constituer partie de l'explication mais
s'ennuie pas le coeur du problème qui
est beaucoup plus pour moi un problème
d'anticipation stratégique
gérer ni vaki pour terminer cette série
de questions
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre est depuis
samedi sont accusés successivement le
club de liverpool ses supporters
viennent accuser les victimes mais aussi
les grévistes du 1er b et même les
jeunes seine-saint-denis d'être
responsables du fiasco qui s'est
déroulée au stade de france monsieur le
ministre vous avez vous même pointé une
fraude massive industrielle organisé de
faux billets madame la ministre vous
avez annoncé kata vous des chiffres de
30 d'accor dont il est supporter sans
lier ou avec des faux billets soit la
moitié de la capacité totale du stade de
france qu'est ce qui vous permet vous en
avez dit un mot malgré tout de tenir l
hop en l'absence de résultats d'une
enquête concrètes d'autant que tous les
observateurs à ce caractère marginal
aubier en atteste notamment les
personnes qui ont été placées en garde à
vue aucune de ces gardes à vue n'a eu
lieu pour des faits d' intrusion
frauduleuse ou de faux billets pire si
ce que chez s'avèrent exacts comment une
production industrielle de cette ampleur
jamais vue auparavant sur un aussi grand
événement a pu passer sous les radars ne
pensez vous pas qu'il s'agisse là on
delà la question du foncier les
coïncidences de la gestion purement
sécuritaire des femmes de football ces
dernières années n'y aurait-il pas a
déploré un manque de moyens de
compétences en matière de gestion des
flux de supporters dans de bonnes
conditions le plus simple ayant été au
cours des dernières années je le
regrette profondément
interdire quasi systématiquement les
déplacements de supporters sans qu'elle
ait interdiction de déplacement à
longueuil cette année pour 380 matches
joués les forces de l'ordre ayant eu
recours aux gaz lacrymogènes y compris à
l'encontre supporters de manière
indiscriminée qui dorment parfois
famille enfants nous rappelle la gestion
de manifestations ces dernières années
dans ce dernier qu il pas urgent de
changer la doctrine maintien de l'ordre
est que ce genre de situations de
tension puisse être évité et de préférer
une désescalade à usage de la force
enfin quid de la formation des stadiers
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé cet après midi
ne serait il pas judicieux
de mieux les préparer de mieux préparer
c'est à dire ce genre de gestion de
grands événements sportifs à venir car
en effet suite à ces événements se pose
évidemment la question la capacité de la
france à accueillir des grands
événements sportifs de grande ampleur je
pense bien sûr du monde en 2003 ainsi
que jose olympiques de 2024 je vous
remercie madame et monsieur le ministre
vous laisser le jeu propose deux
représentations il nous reste cinq
collègues qui veulent poser question
avait redonné la parole tout de suite et
puis les ministres répondront et on
pourra ensuite avec le v l'audition sur
les d'accord thani mohamed soilihi qui
est en visio
sénateurs de
madame la ministre je reconnais qu une
question tout d'abord à vous madame la
ministre avait parlé tout à l'heure
l'indemnisation et de ce qu'ils avaient
achetés de bonne foi paix dédié et qui
n'ont pas pu accéder au stade est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus où vous
n'avez pas encore de retour des
organisateurs
deuxième question
nous savons que
c'est le club de liverpool qui a demandé
une émission de billets papier qui
avaient le pouvoir de refuser
c'est bien qu'ils auraient dû qui aurait
pu refuser c'est bien papier et enfin
dernière question nous savons aussi que
ce club de l'entraîneur de liverpool
avait les supporteurs de liverpool
allait de se rendre en france même non
munis de billets est-ce que vous pensez
que cet appel appuyé jouer dans la
défaillance merci merci madame casabonne
je crois vous avez renoncé à votre
question gd la parole à monsieur
dominati mala benbassa madame brulin et
ensuite le bris dans la faune mais je
devine at il
prêché le ministre d'abord vous êtes
dans une situation difficile parce que
vous ne devriez pas être avec madame la
ministre jeunesse et des sports seul
devant le scénar parce que le
dysfonctionnement ou le fiasco qui a eu
lieu la semaine dernière c'est un fiasco
général qui touche l'ensemble je dirais
des services du gouvernement
mon collègue l'a évoqué assez peu mais
d'abord il ya une défaillance des
systèmes de transport et la défaillance
des systèmes de transport ça fait des
années qu'on la dénonce en ile de france
l'autorité des transports nous sommes
l'une des seules capitales européennes
où les transports sont gérés totalement
par l'état et s'est totalement
défaillant
evènement après événement est l'une des
questions qui se posent pour les jeux
olympiques est ce que nous serons
l'otage des syndicats des sociétés de
transport ou est ce qu'il y aura un
service minimum comme dans ce type
d'événement ça devrait être nécessaire
dans d'autres collectivités
deuxièmement il ya une défaillance de la
fédération française de football c'est
pas la première
jeu rappellerai simplement que le
ministère de tutelle devrait sur la
fédération française de football avec
plus de force affirmé régulièrement ce
qu'il en est je prendrai part d'air
exemple pendant le vide tout simplement
l'arrêt prématuré par rapport aux autres
championnats européens la décision de la
fédération française de football je
pense que la tutelle du ministère de la
jeunesse et des sports sur ce sujet
n'est pas suffisante et qu'il faudra à
l'avenir en tirer les conséquences
troisièmement madame la ministre
jeunesse et des sports vous vous dites
que vous attendez à un rapport du
délégué à
interministériel c'est très sympathique
mais c'est l'ancien préfet de police le
délégué interministériel
la jeunesse aux sports c'est donc un
ancien préfet de police qui va faire un
rapport sur les défaillances qui ont eu
lieu éventuellement au stade de france
c'est curieux mais c'est d'ailleurs il
n'est pas que ancien préfet de police
parce que nous les élus parisiens on
connaît bien il était aussi préfet de
région la dernière fois que j'ai vu
c'était justement pour parler du rer b
et surtout de l'action du gouvernement
pour faire en sorte que très rapidement
il y ait la liaison entre charles de
gaulle et le centre de paris au
détriment de la linière r&b puisque qui
concerne tous les franciliens sous
prétexte il y avait urgence urgence il y
avait une enquête publique et urgence
pour les jeux olympiques et puis
finalement quelque temps après à cause
du vide le gouvernement a renoncé à ses
rapports alors les rapports je sais pas
ce qu'on peut en attendre dans tout cas
je pense que pour votre ministère il
serait bon de prendre véritablement une
distance nécessaire à la suite de ce
crash parce que l'événement plusieurs
collègues l'ont dit c'est les jeux
olympiques et c'est l'image de paris et
si vous partez simplement sur certains
dysfonctionnements
effectivement c'est problématique c'est
la remise en cause l'étude du crash nous
intéresse assez peu ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir quelle est la
réaction du gouvernement pour modifier
des choses allaient venir est-ce que
c'est au niveau du premier ministre ou
est ce simplement le ministre de
l'intérieur
ministre de jeunesse et des sports et
enfin sur la police monsieur le ministre
je ne sais pas si on a sauvé des vivres
la semaine dernière peut-être vous
reprenez d'ailleurs les termes de votre
prédécesseur monsieur castaner lorsqu'il
disait que le préfet de police avait
sauvé des vies lors du but
lors des dégâts sur l'arc de triomphe
c'est ce qu'il avait dit à l'assemblée
nationale à l'époque en en parlant de
l'ancien préfet de police en réalité
vous êtes dans une situation un peu
difficile parce que depuis dix ans vous
êtes le huitième ministre de l'intérieur
depuis 2012 la durée de vie des
ministres de l'intérieur est inférieure
à celle des préfets de police
donc vous êtes ça fait à peu près deux
ans que vous êtes en poste au ministère
vous êtes à l'aube d'un quinquennat vous
commencez à avoir de la bouteille ce
qu'on attend de vous que moi j'attends
de vous c'est des réformes de structures
se sont pas les hommes parce que les
hommes les effectifs on les a les moyens
ils ont été mis dernièrement mais ce
sont des réformes de structure et la
structure de la préfecture de police ça
fait des années et des années qu'on en
parle c'est un serpent de mer et ça ne
fonctionne toujours pas très bien
parfois ça fonctionne c'est une
institution ne se sont pas les hommes
qui travaillent à la préfecture de
police qui sont en cause seles structure
même dans la police nationale de cet
état dans l'état et des événements de
cette importance doivent faire l'objet
d'une révision merci chers collègues
dans la baie de bassar
et puis madame brûla ensuite et le bruit
dans la fourche à la main merci monsieur
le président comme comme vous le savez
mais monsieur madame monsieur madame la
ministre les forces de sécurité
intérieure ne rentre plus dans les
stades pourraient effectuer les
contrôles tous sont effectuées par les
civils la question de l'évaluation et de
la mobilisation des forces de l'ordre
sur le parvis aux alentours du stade des
gars de rebelles et sur les trajets
retour revient à la préfecture de police
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faut
s'interroger sérieusement sur les
consignes données par le préfet de
police on force de l'ordre et est elle
adaptée aux circonstances c'est une
question quand même qu'il faut étudier
et se demander si les consignes ne
devrait pas être plus réactive et
également plus flexible suivant les
circonstances là je crois qu'il ya eu
des consignes en amont qui n'ont pas été
je vu devant la nouvelle situation il
faudrait peut-être le connaître aussi
cela et ne pas se contenter
d'essentialiser
elle et les anglais comme étant des eaux
ligand
possibles et sont enfin c'est je crois
que nous devons plutôt nous en excuser
est de ce qui est arrivé mais là
peut-être il faut arrêter aussi il n'y a
pas de bon spectateurs des mauvais
spectateurs il ya des circonstances des
événements et la conjoncture du moment
merci merci à dame madame cécile brûlant
et ensuite le président laffont
si monsieur le président madame monsieur
le ministre y compris au quasi thème de
cette audition il me semble qu'il y a
quand même non pas seulement un problème
de disproportion entre les moyens
déployés en faveur de l'ordre public et
se déployant en faveur de la sécurité
publique mais un vrai problème de nature
de la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
parce que même après vos explications
monsieur le ministre entendre que pour
que des des supporters ne se fasse pas
écraser il a fallu utiliser du gaz
lacrymogène vous imaginez bien que ça ne
va pas apaiser ceux qui sont déjà très
inquiet de voir la situation que nous
avons connue ce samedi et ça paraît
complètement invraisemblable ensuite sur
vous avez beaucoup évoqué la volonté de
liverpool d'avoir de disposer de billets
papier
qui vous semble vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille mais quelle a été la nature de